alors monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée du projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions de vigilance
sanitaire la parole est à monsieur
olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
et la santé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés
me voici donc devant vous pour la
onzième fois pour vous présenter au nom
du gouvernement un projet de loi qui
porte sur la gestion de la pandémie de
commis de 19
c'est un onzième texte mais c'est un
texte qui est différent des autres dans
l'esprit d'abord du texte nous le
verrons tout à l'heure et au long des
débats et jusque dans le titre même du
texte puisqu'il s'agit non pas cette
fois ci d'un état d'urgence sanitaire
mais bien de vigilance sanitaire c'est à
dire qu'il s'agit de ne pas nous
désarmer quand bien même le virus
montrerait des signes de faiblesse il
s'agit de rester vigilant acteurs actifs
dans la continuité pour ne pas laisser
la moindre prise au virus pour qu'ils
aient enclenche une nouvelle vague dans
notre pays
malgré la lassitude que chacun peut
légitimement éprouver face à cette crise
qui n'épargne aucun pays du globe
faut-il le rappeler nous devons rester
toujours autant mobilisés pour lutter
contre un virus toujours présent dans
notre quotidien nous pouvons aussi
prendre un instant pour nous retourner
et mesurer le chemin parcouru depuis le
début de cette crise ainsi que les
immenses progrès réalisés pour mieux
gérer cette épidémie dans la durée en
france comme dans le monde et limiter au
mieux ses conséquences sanitaires et son
impact sur notre vie quotidienne
ainsi en métropole la vague épidémique
liée à la propagation du variant delta a
pu être contenu sans restriction
généralisée de la circulation des
personnes ni des rassemblements et en
même temps maintenant ouvert l'ensemble
des établissements grâce à la
vaccination massive de la population et
grâce à des outils comme le pass
sanitaire entendait bien là s'il fallait
vous en convaincre à l'heure à laquelle
je vous parle le variant delta très
contagieux ce qu vide 19 circulent en
france comme dans le monde il ya environ
5000 diagnostic réalisé chaque jour dans
notre pays 5000 ce n'est pas rien
5000 ça ne correspond pas non plus à une
vague épidémique et s'il ya çà et là des
signes qui
impose la plus grande vigilance et
l'action déterminée des forces
sanitaires dans les territoires pour
empêcher une nouvelle reprise épidémique
il faut néanmoins rester vigilants et
actifs al'inverse vous avez certains
pays non loin de nous en europe qui sont
obligés de mettre en place des mesures
de couvre-feu de fermeture des commerces
voire de confinement c'est le cas de la
lettonie qui a prononcé un confinement
pour quatre semaines un confinement dur
parce que la lettonie n'a pas pu
suffisamment vacciner sa population
la roumanie est un pays aussi qui nous
inquiète avec un nombre de cas
importants l'angleterre qui affiche un
taux de vaccination bien moins élevé que
le nôtre et qui fait face à des
diagnostics à hauteur de 40 à 50 milles
diagnostic par jour avec son lot de
malades sa pression sanitaires et demain
des copies de long le virus n'est donc
pas disparu et dans certains territoires
de la république dans des territoires
ultramarins il y encore quelques jours
il n'est encore quelques semaines nous
étions obligés d'envoyer force renforts
sanitaires par avion en urgence pour
aider les soignants sur place à faire
face à une vague épidémique extrêmement
extrêmement violente parce que là aussi
la vaccination n'était pas suffisante le
virus n'est donc pas mort mais nous
avons les moyens de faire en sorte que
quand bien même ils continueraient de
cire
et c'est une elle je rappelle grandes
études dans le monde elle est française
elle est sortie la semaine dernière elle
a comparé 11 millions de français
vaccinés 11 millions de français non
vaccinés et cette étude est implacable
le vaccin la vaccination réduit de plus
de 90 % le risque de formes graves chez
les français qui sont soumis au risque
de formes graves c'est-à-dire les
français âgés de 50 ans et plus 90 % de
réduction nous avons encore deux enjeux
au moins en matière de vaccination le
premier enjeu c'est encore ce plus du
million de français fragile parce que
âgées ou malades avec un système
immunitaire qui ne fonctionne pas
suffisamment bien et qui n'ont pas
encore ne serait-ce que reçu la moindre
dose de vaccin nous continuons d'aller
les chercher par là les verts nous
transformons les centres en équipes
mobiles nous allons nous allons au pied
des tours d'immeubles dans les quartiers
nous allons avec les élus locaux
chercher les personnes chez elles en
ruralité pour les vacciner les médecins
les appelle les pharmaciens les appelle
et nous n'abandonnerons jamais ce combat
le deuxième défi qui est devant nous en
matière de vaccination c'est celui des
rappels de vaccination le rappel est
fondamental chez les personnes qui sont
fragiles même si elle ne se considère
pas comme fragiles c'est un fait lorsque
nous avons dépassé lorsqu'on est au delà
de 65 ans le système immunitaire n'a pas
la même mémoire que le système
immunitaire de quelqu'un de jeune et le
vaccin à apprend au système immunitaire
à reconnaître le virus et le moment venu
à le combattre pour empêcher l'infection
mais un système immunitaire au delà de
65 ans il a besoin qu'on se rappelle à
son souvenir qu'on à nouveau actif qu'on
le fasse travailler pour qu'ils se
souviennent dans la durée que le
coronavirus ne doit pas rentrer dans
l'organisme s'il se présente de la même
manière les personnes qui ont des
maladies chroniques qui fatigue le
système immunitaire ont aussi besoin de
ce rappel de vaccination à terme ce
seront 22 millions de nos concitoyens
qui sont appelés à se recevoir ce rappel
les personnes âgées de 65 ans et plus
les personnes malades et l'ensemble des
soignants parce qu'ils sont plus exposés
aux risques de virus mais aussi celles
et ceux qui vivent au quotidien auprès
de personnes qu'on système immunitaire
fragile vous le savez la vaccination de
rappel ces six mois après la dernière
injection donc six mois après
l'injection de janssen quand on est
urgent de seine ou six mois après la
dernière injection de vaccin lorsqu'on a
eu l'un des autres vaccins
il est vraiment fondamental de le faire
à date ce sont 6 millions de français
qui ont atteint ces six mois un peu plus
du tiers a reçu un rappel on peut
considérer que c'est un début mais on ne
peut pas s'en satisfaire et nous devons
véritablement poussé le rappel de
vaccination chez les personnes âgées
sauf à nouveau exposé notre pays à
commencer par les personnes concernées
elle même au risque de développer des
formes graves et elle attrape le virus
nous avons développé les moyens de
d'éviter les vagues épidémiques et les
vagues sanitaires que nous avons connus
nous en connaissant la méthode elle est
éprouvée nous avons le recul et les
études scientifiques
nous devons faire en sorte de continuer
à nous protéger dans la durée nous
sommes à plus de 51 millions de français
vaccinés et près de 50 millions
totalement vacciner qui l'eût cru il ya
encore quelques mois même lorsque je me
présenter devant vous pour le dernier
projet de loi qui portait sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et pourtant nous
l'avons fait les français l'ont fait
avec l'aide de tous est la
responsabilité de tous c'est cet esprit
de responsabilité
qui doit en mon sens régner dans les
débats que nous ouvrons avec le
parlement à l'heure de redemander la
confiance du des parlementaires pour
nous permettre de prendre si la
situation impose toutes les mesures pour
protéger la population
un moment très particulier qu'est le
moment où nous entrons dans la période
froide la période hivernale d'abord
automnale le temps est plus humide il
fait plus froid dehors et ses conditions
climatiques sont de nature à favoriser
la propagation des virus nous le savions
avec la grippe nous le savons désormais
avec le kobe de 19 c'est près de 30% de
circulation en plus du virus dans ces
conditions automnales et hivernales et
donc certainement pas venu le moment de
nous désarmer face au virus nous ne
devons pas donner la possibilité au
virus de se faufiler dans aucun
interstices et provoquer de nouvelles
vagues épidémiques nous avons payé pour
savoir à chaque fois qu'elles sont les
dégâts que cela peut engendrer dans
notre pays
très schématiquement le gouvernement
demande donc aux parlementaires de nous
permettre si la situation l exige de
prendre des mesures et ce jusqu'au 31
juillet 2022 nous demandons d'abord la
possibilité nous demandons d'abord la
possibilité de prolonger de prolonger
l'état trans histoire qui de l'état de
sortie d' état d'urgence sanitaire je
rappelle que nous ne sommes pas en état
d'urgence sanitaire à l'exception de
territoires ultramarins mais nous
demandons la possibilité d'actionner des
leviers si la situation sanitaire devait
l'exiger
comme nous sommes en train de le faire
avec des jauges avec des règles en
matière de port de masques et tout cela
nous savons que nous en aurons besoin de
toute façon jusqu'à l'été à venir nous
en aurons besoin ce qu'elle était à
venir il est inutile de se reposer la
question dans trois mois non trois mâts
le virus n'aura pas disparu la france il
n'aura pas disparu de la planète et nous
avons besoin de pouvoir s'y buzz si
nécessaire activer ces mesures de la
même manière je disais nous ne sommes
pas en état d'urgence sanitaire nous ne
sommes pas en état d'urgence sanitaire
est depuis des mois de cela mais si la
situation devait l'exiger nous demandons
la possibilité de pouvoir déclencher à
tout moment l'état d'urgence sanitaire
nous espérons ne pas avoir besoin de le
faire nous n'avons pas eu à le faire en
métropole y compris pendant la quatrième
vague et malgré la contagiosité du
variante delta mais si la situation
l'exigé nous ne devons pas attendre nous
ne devrions pas attendre et nous vous
demandons la confiance pour pouvoir le
déclencher aujourd'hui il je rappelle
d'ailleurs que
1 en cas de prononciation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire il faudrait de toute
façon dans le mois que le gouvernement
se présente devant le parlement en vue
de répondre aux questions et de
d'expliquer les raisons pour lesquelles
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
prononcé et recueillir à nouveau la
confiance du parlement pour pouvoir le
prolonger un décret en conseil des
ministres restera nécessaire à cette fin
et sa prorogation au delà d'une durée
d'un mois ne pourrait être autorisée que
par le mup par le parlement il s'agit
donc pas d'une information mais d'un
rôle décisif et décisionnel du parlement
pour le seul territoire de la guyane
confronté à une circulation virale
toujours inquiétante est élevé l'état
d'urgence sanitaire en vigueur sera
prorogé jusqu'au 31 décembre les autres
territoires ultramarins en sortiront
plus tard le 15 novembre prochain étant
précisé que le gouvernement peut par
décret pris après avis du conseil
scientifique
il peut décider d'y mettre un terme
anticipé si la situation le permet c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous avons décidé la
semaine dernière pour la réunion
donc le projet de loi proroge jusqu'au
31 juillet le régime
de gestion de la sortie de la crise
sanitaire et proroge la possibilité
encore une fois de déclencher un état
d'urgence sanitaire si c'était
absolument nécessaire il proroge jusqu'à
la même date le 31 juillet 2022 la
possibilité de mobiliser par voie
réglementaire
le pass sanitaire qui a fait ses preuves
pour concilier le maintien de nombreuses
activités avec une maîtrise de la
circulation du virus je redis les choses
je les affirme si nous n'avions pas eu
le pass sanitaire du fait de la
quatrième vague épidémique que nous
avons connue cet été de la virulence du
virus nous aurions probablement étaient
conduits à refermer des établissements
recevant du public a refermé des
commerces et à restreindre davantage les
libertés publiques pour sauver des lits
nous n'avons pas eu besoin de le faire
parce que le parlement nous a permis
d'activer le pass tony terre là aussi il
s'agit bien d'une possibilité de prendre
tout ou partie des mesures permise par
le régime sortie et d'activer ou de
maintenir le passe dans les conditions
fixées par le parlement par la loi du 31
mai puis par la loi du 5 août et non
d'une prolongation automatique de ce
dispositif n'allons pas faire croire
mesdames et messieurs les députés que
nous serions en train d'annoncer aux
français que jusqu'au 31 juillet il y
aurait ou l'état d'urgence ou les
mesures de sortie d'état d'urgence avec
des jauges ou le pastel iter je redis
les choses parce que j'entends beaucoup
de contre-vérités depuis quelques temps
il s'agit de possibilité d'activer si la
situation sanitaire l'exigé
comme l'indiqué le gouvernement la
perspective d'un allégement du pass sera
examiné à la mi-novembre avec
l'éclairage des autorités scientifiques
en outre le gouvernement partage
l'objectif d'un encadrement du recours
au pass sanitaires tels qui ressort
d'ailleurs des débats qui ont eu lieu en
commission des lois le gouvernement sera
donc favorable aux propositions visant à
substituer aux seuls seuil d'incidence
adopté en commission un encadrement du
recours aux facilités reposant sur
plusieurs critères il y aura
probablement le side incidence il y aura
probablement d'autres critères de la
charge sanitaire par exemple la
dynamique épidémique et pourquoi pas la
vaccination de rappel parce que encore
une fois ci un territoire avait un
rappel insuffisant vaccination et que le
dit ruth repartait on serait très
clairement collectivement en situation
périlleuse et tout cela je le rappel
sous le contrôle du juge pendant la
période visée par ces provocations nous
avons prévu un dispositif renforcé
d'information du parlement avec la
remise d'ici à la mi février d'un
rapport qui exposera les mesures prises
pour freiner l'épidémie et qui
justifiera le cas échéant la nécessité
de les maintenir pour la période
restante la remise de ce rapport
permettra de disposer d'une clause de
revoyure qui viendra en complément de
l'ensemble des initiatives prises depuis
le début de la crise afin d'assurer
l'information du parlement sur la
gestion de crise je pense en particulier
aux dossiers qui sont transmis chaque
semaine aux deux assemblées assemblée
nationale et sénat ainsi qu'aux réunions
du comité de liaison qui sont organisées
régulièrement par le premier ministre le
gouvernement et par ailleurs tout à fait
favorables aux compléments et précision
qui ont été apportées sur ce sujet en
commission à l'initiative conjointe du
rapporteur et de la majorité je pense à
l'enrichissement du rapport par des
indicateurs sanitaires à la remise à
second rapport d'ici la mi mai ou encore
à la production d'information mensuel
sur les mesures prises et leur impact
sur la situation sanitaire cet exercice
de transparence vient bien sûr en
complément des prérogatives dont vous
disposez mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour contrôler l'action du
gouvernement par ailleurs le texte
améliore plusieurs outils importants
pour garantir l'efficacité de la gestion
de l'épidémie dans les prochains mois
ainsi nous proposons de renforcer la
lutte contre la fraude au pass sanitaire
en augmentant les sanctions encourues
pour l'établissement la proposition ou
l'utilisation d'un faux-pas sanitaires
et en permettant à l'assurance maladie
de contrôler les certificats de contre
indication à la vaccination
s'agissant de l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants le texte prévoit
d'améliorer son contrôle et son
effectivité notamment en autorisant les
écoles de santé à contrôler son respect
par les étudiants en santé par ailleurs
nous proposons et ça vous en avez aussi
l'habitude désormais de prolonger
jusqu'à fin juillet les systèmes
d'information si depp et contact ecops
vide qui sont comme vous le savez des
outils indispensables pour suivre la
situation sanitaire est cassé les
chaînes de contamination sur ce sujet
le gouvernement présentera un amendement
permettant aux directeurs
d'établissements scolaires d'accéder aux
informations nécessaires concernant
leurs élèves pour renforcer la campagne
de vaccination et de dépistages dans les
écoles les collèges et les lycées ainsi
vous savez que le protocole sanitaire
dans les établissements scolaires a été
changé qu'il n'ya pas systématiquement
la fermeture d'une classe est ce que
nous souhaitons développer il s'était en
expérimentation et pour ne pas pour
éviter la fermeture d'une classe il faut
permettre aux directeurs d'établissement
de savoir si les élèves sont oui ou non
protégés contre la copie enfin le texte
proroge un nombre ciblé de mesures
d'accompagnement qui permettront de
faire face en tant que de besoin aux
conséquences de la crise sanitaire en
matière d'activité partielle de
fonctionnement des organes délibérants
des collectivités territoriales ou de
durée de validité de certaines décisions
administratives individuel vous l'aurez
compris ce projet de loi qui vous est
soumis ne bouleverse pas l'économie
générale de la gestion de crise
sanitaire il porte sur la vigilance
nécessaire dans la durée face à ce virus
et il conforte au contraire les
différents outils dont nous disposons
pour répondre aux risques sanitaires
dans un contexte toujours incertain face
au risque de voir émerger de nouveaux
variants plus transmissible plus
pathogène c'est cette grande vigilance
qui s'imposent anticipation et
réactivité sont les fils conducteurs de
notre réponse à l'épidémie de kobe 19 et
ce sont bien ces principes essentiels
qui irrigue le texte que le gouvernement
vous présente je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à mme c'est jean piat pont rapporteur de
la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation
l'administration générale de la
république
pour dix minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame le président de la
commission des lois chers collègues le
bilan estival de la lutte contre le coc
vide de la copie de 19 et nuancé la
quatrième vague n'ayant pas affectés de
la même manière la métropole et les
autres maires malgré tout nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà tiré une leçon de cette
période notre stratégie sanitaire
reposant sur la vaccination et le passé
ni terre a prouvé son efficacité pour
combattre le virus et éviter tout
nouveau confinement répondant ainsi aux
attentes légitimes de nos concitoyens
cet été le déploiement massif de la
vaccination et la mise en oeuvre réussie
du passani terre ont permis en métropole
de réduire drastiquement la portée de la
quatrième vague tout en préservant la
reprise des activités dans les outre-mer
en revanche la situation demeure
délicate qu'il s'agisse des antilles ou
s'est récemment rendu une mission de la
commission des lois de la polynésie de
la nouvelle calédonie ou encore de la
guyane la verrue lance du variant delta
et surtout un trou faible taux de
vaccination de la population ont conduit
à une situation catastrophique frappant
sévèrement nos compatriotes ultramarins
c'est dans ce contexte que nous
examinons maintenant ce projet de loi le
dixième texte contre l'épidémie à être
examiné par le parlement depuis le 18
mars 2020 ce texte vise à projet dans le
contexte particulier du changement de
législature les deux outils juridiques
de la stratégie de lutte contre
l'épidémie et régime de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est celui de la loi du 31 mai
2009 21
c'est l'objet des articles 1 et 2
cette double prorogation demeure
indispensable
l'épidémie n'a malheureusement pas
disparu et constitue toujours une menace
sanitaire le conseil scientifique
souscrit à ces deux mesures et dans son
avis appelle les pouvoirs publics à
anticiper certains aspects susceptibles
de provoquer un rebond épidémique je
pense notamment à la progression
constante du variante d qui présentent
un risque accru de contagiosité au
ralentissement de la protection offerte
par les vaccins pendant ce temps où se
déploie la campagne de rappel pour
l'injection de la troisième dose ou
encore à l'arrivée de l'automne et de
l'hiver propice à la circulation virale
si la situation s'est aujourd'hui
nettement améliorée certain frémissement
se font sentir localement sur le
territoire tandis que la situation en
outre-mer reste préoccupante cette
situation milite pour la plus grande
vigilance est donc pour les mesures
prévues par le ce projet de loi en ce
qui concerne l'article 1
l'utilité du cadre juridique de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire activable en cas de
catastrophe sanitaire demeure
incontestable nous en avons eu la preuve
en commission mercredi dernier lorsque
notre président expliqué que le contexte
de faible vaccination de la population
en martinique en guadeloupe nécessite
d'anticiper la survenue d'une possible
cinquième bague si cette éventualité
venait à se produire il serait
irresponsable d'avoir renoncé au seul
outil juridique adapté qui permettent
d'y faire face et de protéger la santé
de la population en effet en dehors de
l'avionique vaccination seuls les
mesures d'intégration de sortie du
domicile permettent de freiner
brutalement efficacement l'épidémie je
rappelle aux demandes que l'article 1er
n'a pas pour effet de permettre
l'instauration sans condition de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire son application dans
le temps restent soumises au régime de
l'article elle tirait 31 13 du code de
la santé publique qui conditionne sa
prorogation au delà de quatre semaines
un vote du parlement
c'est ce qui est fait le fait de
disposer d'un cadre facilement
immédiatement activable pour faire face
de manière réactive à un retour en force
de l'épidémie ne signifie pas qu'ils
soient utilisés n'importe comment la
gestion efficace de la quatrième vague
cet été en métropole en témoigne elle
n'a pas conduit au déclenchement de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ni à la prise
des mesures les plus contraignantes pour
les français j'en viens à l'article 2
qui a pour objet de projets également
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 le régime de
gestion de la crise sanitaire
mises en oeuvre par la loi du 31 mai
2021 il sera applicable sur l'ensemble
du territoire national sans fard guyane
où l'état d'urgence perdurera jusqu'au
31 décembre de cette année en raison
d'une situation qui demeure très facile
dans ce territoire la loi du 31 mai 2021
doit être appréhendée comme une boîte à
outils utiles au gouvernement pour gérer
la crise avec réactivité et efficacité
dans un contexte national qui ne saurait
se réduire à la situation en métropole
et aussi mondial où le virus continue de
circuler et de muter ainsi la présente
prorogation rassurez-vous n'entraînera
pas de l'application générale est
automatique du passé ni terre jusqu'au
31 juillet 2022
l'avenir même si vous pouvez nous
satisfaire du bilan de cette mise en
oeuvre le déploiement du pass effectué
sans heurts et sans difficulté ainsi que
la formidable accélération de la
vaccination au cours de l'été ont permis
de dissiper les craintes parfois
légitimes et les vives critiques pas
toujours fondées émises à l'encontre du
pass lors de la discussion de la loi du
5 août 2021 les français se sont un
constat blement approprié facilement cet
outil précieux sésame de leur liberté
retrouvée
permettez moi chers collègues une mise
en garde si nous supprimons toute
possibilité de recourir au pass and it
erp ou si nous nous rendons inapplicable
comme certains semblent le souhaiter la
seule alternative à une ruse résurgence
épine milk serait la fermeture des
établissements où le retour au
confinement ce dont personne ne veut
notre commission des lois a adopté
vendredi un amendement encadrant
l'utilisation du pin sanitaire si je
partage la volonté d'encadrer cet outil
cela ne doit pas compromettre ni sa mise
en oeuvre ni son efficacité
or l'accoutrement introduit me semble
présenter deux écueils d'abord il
retient une logique de
territorialisation généralisée qu'il ne
correspond pas aux réalités pandémique
locale
il s'appuie sur un indicateur fils est
intangible pas toujours le plus
approprié je vous pose donc avec les
groupes de la majorité parlementaire
un amendement de compromis afin
d'ajuster ce contrôle de l'utilisation
du pass pour lui conserver une plus
grande précision de ses possibilités
d'application notre commission a
également renforcé le volet du
dispositif consacrée au contrôle
parlementaire en avançant au 15 février
2022 la date limite de remise d'un
premier rapport du gouvernement qui
pourra faire l'objet d'un débat et en
prévoyant la mise d'un autre rapport en
mai ainsi que deux rapports mensuels
d'étape dans ce même registre nous avons
projet adapté le rapport sur l'impact
économique et sanitaire du passe à
travers un nouvel article 2 bis
l'article 2 modifie également le régime
de sanctions de la fraude sanitaires
afin de garantir la réussite de la
sortie de crise deux nouvelles
incriminations été créée la première
concerne le cas d'un d'utilisation
frauduleuse d'appât sanitaire puni d'une
contravention de 4e classe la seconde
réprima création ou usage de faux d'un
tel document sanctionné d'une peine de
cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000
euros d'amendé sanction proportionnée
comme l'a révélé le conseil d'état ce
même article permet en outre médecins
conseils de contrôler le certificat
médical de contre-indication vaccinale
dans le cadre de passes annie terre
comme déjà la loi du 5 1 ou 2021 pour
les personnes concernées par
l'obligation vaccinale
parcours dix nations les articles à et
de l'article iv proroge jusqu'au va 31
juillet 2002 les systèmes d'information
mise en oeuvre afin de lutter contre
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 ces dispositifs
que vous connaissez déjà très bien
contact au vide et cidep contribuer
inéluctablement à la lutte contre
l'épidémie est donc absolument
nécessaire que leur utilisation soit
prorogé janvier aux autres dispositions
du texte l'article 3 clarifient et
précisent les modalités de contrôle du
respect de l'obligation vaccinale afin
de renforcer sa mise en oeuvre l'article
3 en particulier apporte des précisions
sur le contrôle de l'obligation
vaccinale des étudiants et élèves des
écoles de santé permettant d'alléger les
ars et modifier le régime de sanctions
en cohérence avec l'article de la
commission a rétabli le mécanisme de la
formation de l'ordre le professionnel de
santé relève lorsqu'une procédure est
engagée contre lui il nous a en effet
semblé nécessaire d'assurer la formation
des ordres professionnels grâce à des
manquements déontologiques d'uribe la
procédure disciplinaire demeure inchangé
et reste régie par le droit commun
l'article 5 auront jusqu'au 31 juillet
2022 trois aménagements concernant
l'activité partielle pour certaines
personnes les aides exceptionnelles pour
les titulaires de droits d'auteur et les
un supplément assouplissement au
fonctionnement des assemblées
délibérantes locale je vous propose
également de proroger les aménagements
portée aux missions des services de
santé au travail
enfin l'article 6 prévoit d'habilité le
gouvernement à prendre des ordonnances
en matière d'activité partielle de
longue durée et de fonctionnement des
assemblées de copropriété
notre commission a remplacé
l'habilitation portant sur la validité
des titres des gens de mer en nouvelle
calédonie et en polynésie française par
une inscription irait dans le texte de
la prolongation de cette validité en
conclusion chers collègues je vous
invite à adopter sans état d'âme ce
projet de loi qui offre les outils
nécessaires pour réagir avec promptitude
efficacité en fonction des circonstances
je vous remercie
merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à madame la présidente de la
commission des lois madame il ya elles
meurent en privé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous voici à nouveau
réunis pour examiner un nouveau texte
relatif à la crise sanitaire ça n'est
plus un texte relatif à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais c'est bien un texte de
vigilance sanitaire qui s'inscrit dans
la sortie de cette crise sanitaire pour
accompagner le gouvernement et
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens pour
pouvoir lutter efficacement contre
l'épidémie tout en préservant nos
libertés je crois que dans ce contexte
de crise sanitaire
il est toujours important de rappeler
que nous n'avons plus pu tous compter
sur l'état de droit l'état de droit a
tenu pendant cette crise sanitaire et
nous a permis de faire face dans le cas
de nos les règles démocratiques l'état
de droit c'est quoi c'est le parlement
c'est le conseil d'état c'est le conseil
constitutionnel c'est le gouvernement
qui a agi dans un cadre réglementaire
que nous lui avons fixés et qu'il ne
sait pas il ne s'est pas arrogé des
pouvoirs en dehors de tout cadre et ses
pouvoirs ont à chaque fois était
contrôlé encadrés et suivis je crois
qu'il ne faut pas laisser à penser à nos
concitoyens que nous donnerions à chaque
fois un blanc seing au gouvernement ça
n'est pas le cas et ça n'est pas le cas
depuis le début et mes chers collègues
depuis le début nous avons pu compter
sur un certain nombre d'entre vous
quelles que soient vos groupes
politiques pour nous accompagner pour
accompagner le gouvernement pour lutter
contre cette épidémie
il en avait besoin il avait besoin de
tout le monde et moi je me rappelle
qu'en mars 2020 lorsque nous étions que
quelques-uns dans cet hémicycle nous
avons voté unanimement pour donner les
pouvoirs au gouvernement pour faire face
à cette crise sanitaire et nous avons
obtenu une commission mixte paritaire
parce que nos collègues sénateurs ont
pris à ce moment là leur responsabilité
et cet été quand nous avons dû sortir de
la crise sanitaire et étendre le pass
annie terre nous avons trouvé également
nos collègues sénateurs à nos côtés pour
donner au gouvernement la possibilité de
faire à cette crise avec ces outils
donc
je ne vois pas où l amateurisme en cela
donc un état de droit qui permet de
faire face à cette épidémie c'est quoi
c'est un débat démocratique nous en
sommes aujourd'hui au 10e texte de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et des textes
de vigilance est sorti nous avons fait
un bilan notre jour en commission des
lois ces 23 % du temps de la commission
des lois depuis mars 2020 qui est
consacré à la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire 23% monsieur le ministre de la
santé est devenue le ministre le plus
auditionné en commission des lois ça
n'était pas évident enfants nous en
sommes ravis monsieur le ministre parce
que c'est toujours non c'est toujours un
plaisir parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser le gouvernement
est toujours là pour répondre aux
questions des parlementaires sur les
questions de la crise donc un débat
parlementaire avec des débats en
commission mais oui c'est normal me faut
le rappeler parce que c'est normal de le
rappeler aussi parce que l'on ce que
l'on entend parfois dans la rue dans
certaines émissions de télé ou dans vos
bouches c'est que justement ce débat
parlementaire n'a pas lieu or il a lieu
et c'est normal qu'il a lieu qu'ils
aient lieu et nous sommes bien d'accord
là-dessus ensemble unanimement débat
parlementaire encadrement des pouvoirs
que l'on attend dé laisser madame la
présidente poursuit votre débat apprécié
monsieur gosselin le pauvre là et
d'interrompre le slam s'exprimer
encadrement des pouvoirs que nous
donnons au gouvernement pour faire face
à cette crise nous les conditionnons ses
pouvoirs nous indiquons nous donnons des
critères d'exercice encore aujourd'hui
nous avons déposé un amendement
concernant le pass sanitaire qui permet
d'en limiter l'usagé de le critt et
reese et donc nous encadrons les
pouvoirs du gouvernement
nous avons demandé une information
constante du parlement depuis le début
de la crise monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez rappelé c'est plus de 16 rapports
sur les mesures prises aux ti de
l'organisation de la sortie de l'état
d'urgence 30 rapport au titre de l'état
d'urgence en sauveur en lui même 5
rapport sur l'impact du passé ni terre
sur l'activité professionnelle et ses
rapports et c'est important que nos
concitoyens le sache également son
public ils sont publiés et accessible
sur le site de la commission des lois
ils sont référencés nous avons un onglet
vigilance sanitaire est tous ces
rapports sont accessibles sont
consultables je regrette d'ailleurs
qu'il ne soient pas suffisamment
consultés que ce soit par léman
parlementaire ou par le public parce
qu'ils existent et ils sont extrêmement
précis donc débat encadrement
informations et enfin control contrôle
ce sont les questions au gouvernement ce
sont les réunions de commission des lois
ce sont les déplacements sur le terrain
monsieur gosselin monsieur mazamet deux
vice présidents viennent de
m'accompagner une semaine en outre-mer
pour contrôler l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en guadeloupe et en martinique
nous avons sur le terrain échanger avec
les acteurs locaux avec les préfets avec
les policiers avec les gendarmes avec
les comités citoyens pour justement voir
comment cet état d'urgence s'appliquait
très concrètement et quelles étaient les
difficultés qui pouvaient être soumis
donc moi je crois aujourd'hui que dans
le cadre de notre débat démocratique
indispensable et nécessaire
il faut que chacun joue son rôle mais il
faut aussi que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités merci
alors mes chers collègues j'ai refus de
monsieur damien abad et des membres du
groupe l'est républicain une motion de
rejet préalable déposé en application de
l'article de 91 alinéa 5 du règlement
la parole est à monsieur philippe
gosselin pour une durée je lui rappelle
qui n'excédera pas 15 minutes
merci monsieur le président de ce rappel
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues chacun oui en effet prendra
ses responsabilités je saisi la balle au
bond madame la présidente parce que nous
avons le groupe l'est républicain pris
nos responsabilités
il y a dix neuf mois en votant le texte
sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire la
situation l'exigé nous ne savions pas où
nous allions il était
or tant que l'ensemble soit
juridiquement encadré
aujourd'hui 19 mois après monsieur le
ministre de la santé nous ressort si je
puis me permettre cette expression à peu
près les mêmes arguments et des
arguments d'autorité
il serait inutile nous dit vous monsieur
le ministre de réunir le parlement
puisque de toute façon jusqu'au 31
juillet les choses sont donnés bravo
quelle perspicacité quelle vision à long
terme être aussi sur des choses a dit
moi ça mérite les félicitations de
l'assemblée et de la représentation
nationale
évidemment je serais beaucoup plus de
critiques
depuis des mois et des mois nous
enchaînons les prorogation de l'état
d'urgence et des sorties d'état
d'urgence nous n'en voyons pas le goût
l'état de droit c'est évidemment un
droit encadré madame la présidente
mais depuis des mois nous vivons sans
doute conformément à l'état de droit
mais dans un état d'exception dans un
état exorbitant du droit commun qui ne
concilie pas toujours comme il le
faudrait les libertés individuelles les
libertés collectives des grands
principes fondamentaux et la sécurité
sanitaire
depuis des mois nous sommes dans une
forme de banalisation de cet état
d'urgence et de cette sortie d'état
d'urgence
mois après mois vous nous dites c'est
bientôt fini mais au fur et à mesure que
nous avançons le temps se défile et la
ligne d'horizon voyez les noms nouveaux
de certains partis politiques la ligne
d'horizon se défile sous nos pieds et en
réalité aujourd'hui ce qui est en cause
ce ne sont pas des moyens que nous ne
voulons pas vous donner c'est un
contrôle démocratique celui madame la
présidente qui en effet est nécessaire
dans un état de droit or que nous
propose ce texte je reviendrai sur le
contenu de forme mais que nous propose
t'il déjà dans un premier temps c'est
d'enjamber pendant dix mois la
représentation nationale
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022
et pour quel motif parce que nous
suspendons nos travaux le 28 février et
qu'il y a des échéances évidemment
importantes élections présidentielles
élections législatives mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire des travaux
suspendus ce n'est pas la fin de notre
mandat notre mandat il s'exerce jusqu'au
17 juin
2022 il suffit d'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour de nos travaux des éléments des
débats sur l'état d'urgence sur la crise
sanitaire pour que nous soyons présents
il ne devait pas y avoir de session
extraordinaire début septembre pourtant
le 7 septembre nous étions tous ici
présents et sans rechigner alors on nous
dit oui mais de réunir le parlement ça
prend du temps oui cet été nous avons
passé 24 heures de plus et sur un
week-end en plus 24 heures de plus que
ce que le gouvernement avait prévu c'est
compliqué quand même d'écouter le
parlement le laisser parler 24 heures
mais ceci étant on a bien compris que le
président de la république et la
majorité en réalité n'avait que faire de
notre droit d'amendement et des droits
du parlement je le city hier le
président de la république qui nous dit
le droit d'amendement est sans doute
légitime mais il est clair que sur ce
sujet une réforme de nos institutions de
la constitution s'impose voilà c'est
assez dit c'est clair dans une prochaine
mandature nous aurons un droit de parole
encore plus court et aujourd'hui nous
nous trouvons avec un enjambement de 10
mois sans que le parlement puisse être
réunies
ce n'est pas sérieux ce n'est pas
acceptable
il n'est pas question encore une fois de
refuser la vaccination
ce n'est pas mon propos ça n'a jamais
été le propos des républicains qui se
sont toujours engagés pour cette
vaccination il ya aujourd'hui plus de 50
millions de nos concitoyens qui sont
vaccinés et c'est heureux moi même j'ai
eu l'accord vide et je sais que j'ai pu
évité grâce à la vaccination
une forme sans doute plus grave comme
certains de mes proches comme les vôtres
donc pas de faux débat pas de débat
binaire où il y aurait les bons et les
mauvais citoyens les bons et les mauvais
parlementaire ça suffit effectivement
ces arguments d'autorité où tout doit
être décidé par l'exécutif
parce que le parlement sera en congé
entre guillemets et parce qu'elle ne
plaît pas finalement à la majorité et au
président de la république de de voir si
besoin était si sa flambée avoir un
nouveau débat parlementaire
effectivement pendant la campagne
présidentielle
faut-il craindre à ce point le débat
démocratique pour le renvoyer au mois de
juillet 2021 faut-il craindre à ce point
les réactions populaires pour renvoyer
au milieu des vacances de nouveaux
débats parlementaires faut-il craindre à
ce point cette assemblée pour renvoyer à
une autre mandature une autre
législature un débat qui doit être
démocratique
je trouve cette attitude très
dérangeante et dans l'esprit contraire
d'une certaine façon oui à l'état de
droit alors qu'on nous parle de
frémissement oui je l'entends
effectivement rien n'est définitivement
assurée avec l'aco vide rien ne permet
de dire qu'il n'y aura pas ici ou là et
peut-être même ici et là à nouveau une
crise nous étions en effet il y a quinze
jours avec la présidente de la
commission des lois et notre collègue
mazars vice-président dans les antilles
guadeloupe et martinique et nous pouvons
attester évidemment et nous sommes bien
d'accord sur ce point nous pouvons
attester des grandes difficultés
rencontrés là-bas je pourrais aussi avec
une casquette nouvelle calédonie a testé
des difficultés en nouvelle calédonie
mais aussi en polynésie et aussi en
guyane et dans les outre-mers pas de
façon générale mais assez singulièrement
c'est ce qui nous a amenés à voter je le
rappelle ici à
l'unanimité le texte qui s'applique dans
les outre-mer depuis septembre et sans
rechigner parce que objectivement il y
avait des raisons de le faire alors
pourquoi voudriez vous que demain ou
après demain c'est à dire après février
et avant le 31 juillet nous soyons dans
une posture de roger quand les faits
peuvent s'imposer les faits peuvent être
têtu syli a nécessité d'un état
d'urgence s'il ya nécessité d'une sortie
de l'état d'urgence et peut-être aussi
d'une certaine façon de passe et de
moyens particuliers oui nous sommes
prêts à vous les donner mais à condition
qu'il y ait un vrai débat et pas
simplement la remise d'un rapport dont
on nous fait l'aumône de l'avoir quinze
jours avant notre départ et l'aumône de
pouvoir ce n'est qu'une simple faculté
organiser le casa chez en un débat en
commission permanente ou en séance
publique allez
c'est c'est un point extrêmement limité
c'est une faculté et juste avant de se
séparer et il n'est pas question d'un
vrai vote devrait engagement
démocratique et parlementaire et cette
clause de revoyure madame la présidente
que vous évoquez en dix ans mais nous
sommes là depuis dix fois on soit nous
avons eu les débats ici oui c'est vrai
que nous avons eu plusieurs fois des
débats sur cet état d'urgence la sortie
le pass sanitaire j'en passe et des
meilleurs mais à chaque fois c'est sous
la contrainte des événements que cette
clause s'impose depuis le début et nous
en avons même fait une proposition de
rapport avec sacha oulié majorité comme
opposition une proposition de rapport
c'est une clause de revoyure tous les
trois mois c'est quand même pas sorcier
une fois par trimestre on se retrouve
pour un débat démocratique sur un sujet
qui concerne effectivement l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens
et bien non à chaque fois c'est refuser
et l'a à nouveau et c'est pas simplement
trois mois ces dix mois ce n'est pas
acceptable
je vous le dis très sincèrement alors
nous avons notre collègue pont qui dit
que le contexte de changements de
législature nous impose tout cela mais
mon cher collègue je vous le redis les
yeux dans les yeux vous êtes rapporteur
encore pour quelques temps nous sommes
tous députés pour quelque temps et moi
je suis prêt à vous retrouver une
nouvelle fois au mois de février au mois
de mars c'est devenu un tel bonheur de
pouvoir échanger monsieur le rapporteur
avec vous et et monsieur le ministre qui
prête beaucoup d'attention comme
toujours aux propos que l'on peut tenir
qui s'ennuient pour ne pas employer un
terme sans doute plus directe qui
s'ennuie à chaque fois qu'il doit
effectivement discuter débattre avec la
représentation nationale parce qu'en
réalité le seul terme que vous avez en
bouche depuis plusieurs mois c'est
prorogé prorogé projet est prorogée eh
bien oui prorogeant si besoin était mais
prorogeant en faisant attention et en
prenant en compte aussi la réalité des
territoires
j'en viens à cet aspect de
territorialisation qui a été demandée
par nombre d'entre nous et depuis de
longs mois et dont un amendement a
permis un petit aboutissement devrait le
dire aurait pu permettre un petit bout
d'aboutissement avec l'amendement de
pacôme rupins eh bien non c'était sans
doute un mirage car cet amendement qui
était intéressant cohérent qui
permettait dire écoutez voilà on ne voit
pas qu'une tête il n'y a pas une
uniformité de toutes les décisions parce
qu'il n'ya pas uniformité des éléments
liés à la coved sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'était trop simple puisque
la majorité ça a été dit il ya quelques
instants par le rapporteur la majorité
vient de déposer un nouvel amendement
qui rajoute tellement de conditions à la
condition du taux d'incidence qu'en
réalité cet amendement est totalement
siphonné il n'y aura pas de
territorialisation en dehors peut-être
d'un ou deux exemples en particulier
dans les autres hommes r mais si votre
département je prends la manche est un
taux d'incidence de 9,7 pour cent mille
on vous dira ah non ah non non non non
il ya encore beaucoup de risques parce
qu'on ne sait pas dans les hôpitaux on
sait pas ce qu'il peut se passer et puis
comme le disait le ministre il est
inutile de discuter puisque c'est comme
ça jusqu'au 31 juillet donc c'est pas la
peine donc avec un taux d'incidence de
9,7 nous resterons s'il doit y avoir des
couvre feux des passes j'en passe et des
meilleurs nous aurons dans le territoire
de la manche comme dans d'autres
départements une approche nationale
parce que il y avait quand même une
forme de diversité vous dites vouloir
vous en remettre aux territoires à la
confiance des territoires travailler en
confiance avec les élus locaux mais dès
qu en réalité il faut travailler dans
une vision qui est plutôt girondine que
jacobine vous n'êtes pas au rendez vous
et c'est franchement désagréable c'est
franchement déplaisant et c'est un
double discours qui n'est pas juste et
qui n'est pas bon de répéter alors en
conclusion en conclusion tout cela
évidemment nous mène contrairement à
d'habitude c'est vous dire l'état dans
lequel nous sommes contrairement à
d'habitude à vous proposer une motion de
rejet nous avons jusqu'à présent au
groupe l'est républicain
rejeté de telles motions car nous
estimions que le parlement devait
pouvoir s'exprimer il devait y avoir un
certain nombre de mesures qui pouvaient
être mis sur la table là aujourd'hui si
nous délibérons mes chers collègues s'il
ya une majorité sur ce texte ce n'est
pas simplement les clés que nous donnons
au gouvernement mais c'est l'ensemble du
trousseau jusqu'au mois de juillet de
l'année prochaine et ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
il faut oui que le gouvernement puisse
travailler que des mesures puissent être
prises que nos concitoyens puissent être
protégées mais il apparaît c'est quand
même bien l'essentiel dans une
démocratie il apparaît nécessaire qu'un
vrai débat démocratique régulier puisse
se faire aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
simplement le pas ce qui est en jeu ce
n'est pas simplement les équilibres
entre des libertés individuelles et
collectives qui est en jeu c'est
réellement un aspect démocratique d'un
débat que nous devons mener et moins
vous accepté de mener ce débat dans
cette enceinte plus il ya de risques
forts pour qu'ils se fassent sous des
formes plus violente dans la rue avec
des manifestants qui vont peut-être en
profiter pour manipuler le débat ce
n'est pas ce que nous voulons nous
sommes un parti de gouvernement nous
avons toujours assumé nos
responsabilités nous continuerons à le
faire mais par pitié respecter les
institutions respecter la voix du peuple
respecter la voix de la représentation
nationale
merci monsieur gauche bien
alain mais sa collègue
monsieur le ministre
tu veux non pardon à écouter monsieur
gosselin mais c'est pas la première fois
monsieur gosselin que je vous entends et
vous être légitime à le faire
juste vous noterez vous noterez
l'absence totale d'agressivité dans mes
propos à l'égard de la représentation
nationale j'aimerais en être être
bénéficiaire de la même non agressivité
de la part de parlementaires dans les
débats qui démarre j'ai le droit de vous
le demander c'est l'humain qui vous le
demande on n'est pas obligé en
permanence de s'invectiver de la sorte
je pense monsieur gosselin vous nous
reprochez à l'absence de débat démocrate
sans ce débat démocratique
vous nous reprochez doté au parlement
ses pouvoirs de contrôle de vote de
capacité de légiférer vous nous
reprochez ça finalement en boucle et
nous reprocher chat vous nous reprochez
ça à chaque et jl chaque projet de loi
que je suis venue des formes qui portait
sur les mesures pour lesquelles nous
demandions justement la confiance du
parlement monsieur gosselin trouvé
trouvé trouvé un parlement trouver un
parlement qui a été amené à se prononcer
onze fois sur les mesures de gestion de
la crise sanitaire en 18 mois trouver un
parlement monsieur monsieur le député
trouver un parlement monsieur le député
qui était amené à se prononcer en soit
en 18 mois sur la prorogation de mesures
de gestion sanitaire je peux le répéter
on soit si vous le souhaitez il n'y en a
pas monsieur débuté et à chaque fois
qu'on m'avait convoqué la présidente de
la commission des lois a eu la
gentillesse de rappeler je ne savais pas
écouté je le serai désormais que j'étais
le ministre plus convoqué devant
l'histoire de la copie sera
l'actionnaire j'ai aucun problème avec
ça au contraire mais je reviendrai à
chalais fois
arrêté
non ou demande de dates de vous entendre
finissez par vous devez intervenir à ce
niveau-là du débat alors monsieur le
ministre
on va passer du temps ensemble on aura
le temps de parler de débattre des
choses posé je vous redis qu'à chaque
convocation j'ai évidemment répondu
présent à chaque convocation je
répondrais évidemment présent que nous
envoyons des documents complets toutes
les semaines qu'il n'y a aucune
informations dont je dispose dont vous
ne disposez pas dans la suite et qui à
plusieurs reprises c'était encore le cas
la semaine dernière pendant quatre
heures le premier ministre et je suis à
ses côtés réuni les présidents des
groupes parlementaires de l'assemblée
monsieur cordier non mais me fut cordier
1 non monsieur janvier vous demanderez
la parole et vous l'obtiendrez
éventuellement si votre groupe vous des
lignes pour le moment c'est monsieur le
ministre que la parole
donc je redis que à deux reprises nous
n'avons demandé la prorogation des
mesures pour une durée de 10 mois et de
10 mois et demi à deux reprises le
groupe ait l'air s'est opposée la
majorité a voté pour et nous avons
finalement une majorité avec les
sénateurs donc ce n'est pas dans une
question de groupes politiques
puisqu'ils me semble que la majorité
sénatoriale est plutôt de votre bord
mesdames messieurs les députés mesdames
et messieurs les députés aujourd'hui
nous ne demandons pas une prolongation
de prorogation 10 mois et demi mais de
huit mois et demi donc quand vous dites
que la prorogation est plus long qu
autrefois c'est faux c'est la
progression la plus courte que nous
demandons quand vous dites que on voir à
se passer du parlement pour déclencher
quoi que ce soit c'est à nouveau
pardonnez moi non factuels puisque je le
redis et c'est ce que vous vous propose
de voter si nous devions par exemple
déclenché un état d'urgence sanitaire
forcément avant la fin du premier mois
le soyons obligés de revenir devant le
parlement pour avoir un vote favorable
des parlementaires pour poursuivre il ya
également le contrôle du juge tout cela
vous le connaissez très bien vous êtes
donc pardonnez moi dans la même ligne
depuis 18 mois celle qui consiste à
voter non à voter non et ensuite à
trouver les arguments pour nous
expliquer pourquoi en réalité vous le
faites vous faites de la politique
monsieur le député quand vous faites
cela fais de la politique
je vous dis juste je vous dis juste je
vous dis je sais pas c'est pas une
insulte vous êtes parlementaire vous
êtes parlementaire est ce que c'est une
insulte de faire de la politique c'est
pas une insulte assumer le assumer leur
a légué donc j'aurai donc très
tranquillement
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
nous n'en sommes qu'au tout début de ce
débat moi quand je suis ministre quand
j'étais sonné je fais de la politique je
ne prends pas mal vous avez droit je
redis les choses le texte vous le
connaissez le contenu des bâtons du
contenu du texte de ce qu'il ya dedans
non pas extrapoler ce que ce texte ne
dit pas ce texte donne pas les pleins
pouvoirs au gouvernement pendant un an
ce texte nous permet pas de faire ce
qu'on veut le texte se départit pas le
parlement de ses capacités de contrôle
et d'évaluation
c'est tout l'un verse le texte vous
demande de nous donner la confiance pour
pouvoir revenir vers vous si la
situation se présentait merci merci
monsieur min
alors mes chers collègues et je le dis
au député républicain j'espère qu'ils
vont pas m'interrompre quand je vais
annoncer qu'ils ont demandé un scrutin
public
il est annoncé l'enceinte de l'assemblée
avant de procéder à ce serait un public
il ya des explications de vote sur la
motion de rejet préalable je rappelle
qu'elles sont limitées à deux minutes
premier orateur monsieur guillaume
bouffier chat
et voudrait bien l'écouter
le laisser s'exprimer jusqu'au bout
parce que tous les groupes vont y passer
et donc ce petit jeu là peut être gênant
pour tout le monde alors monsieur le
député vous avez et vous seul la parole
merci monsieur le président je suis
certain que mes collègues républicains
nous écouterons a bien entendu sans
surprise nous rejetterons le groupe la
réplique en marche cette motion de rejet
assez surprenante sur le fond je trouve
d'ailleurs que chers collègues gosselin
vous passez à côté des enjeux réels de
ce texte vous passez beaucoup de temps
dans les explications sur la durée sur
la date en fait un focus dessus au
regard même de l'avis du conseil d'état
ce ne sont pas là les vrais enjeux je
pense du texte il vous est proposé dans
les débats et nous aurons un voir des
débats sur les questions de critères sur
les questions de contrôles qui sont là
les vrais enjeux par ailleurs au-delà
des questions d'enjeu il est intéressant
de voir ce que dit cette motion de rejet
au fond notre compréhension des enjeux
actuellement je pense que il ya là dans
votre motion une triple incompréhension
une incompréhension sur la période
sanitaires que nous vivons une période
où effectivement la crise sanitaire et
peut-être sous maîtrise mais où les
inquiétudes sont bien réelles sur les
possibilités de rebond au regard du
rebond que nous connaissons dans
certains territoires au regard de la
campagne de rappel qui a du mal à
démarrer au regard de certains
territoires notamment ultramarins qui
connaissent encore actuellement une
crise particulièrement difficile et nous
ne pouvons pas dans ce temps-là nous
désarmer et abandonner un certain nombre
d'outils deuxièmement vous faites une
incompréhension regard de la période
démocratique dans laquelle nous rentrons
et dans laquelle les françaises et les
français je pense nous demande de la
visibilité nous demande de la visibilité
sur la manière dont nous allons gérer
cette crise et les outils oui les outils
de vigilance qui nous permettront de
maintenir la vie dans les mois qui
viennent qui nous permettront de
maintenir les activités économiques
culturelles et démocratique également
pour chacune et chacun et je pense que
c'est l'ensemble de ces incompréhensions
au delà des incompréhensions également
le sens institutionnel ou alors ce
serait une remise en cause des
institutions
car c'est bien le parlement qui va fixer
le cadre d'utilisation de ces outils de
vigilance et en aucun cas des décisions
qui nous seraient imposées après il ya
une majorité et une opposition animaux
mais réputé la parole est un monsieur
david lorient pour les républicains et
pour deux minutes également
[Applaudissements]
ministres le gouvernement souhaite
légiférer pour reporter à nouveau la fin
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire la date du
31 juillet 2022 la situation actuelle
justifie t'elle ce nouveau report il ya
évidemment et vous l'avez dit des signes
encourageants de reculer l'épidémie qui
sont bien significatif et des
indicateurs évaluant le risque sanitaire
qui sont nettement en baisse la
situation s'est améliorée grâce à la
mobilisation grâce à la vaccination
cependant elle reste vous savez très
contrastée de certains territoires et
notamment dans les outre-mer cette
situation contraste et doit nous emmener
à porter un regard très différenciée sur
l'ensemble des territoires à rester
vigilants mobilisés pour éviter une
nouvelle vague épidémique majeur le
parlement a déjà prouvé par le passé
vous avez dit madame la présidente sa
capacité par le dialogue et le compromis
d'adapter la législation en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation la preuve
est qu'il s'agit du dixième texte sur le
sujet que nous avons étudiés dans cette
crise le parlement doit continuer à
jouer un rôle de contrôle du
gouvernement dans la gestion de la crise
la préservation des libertés publiques
il n'est pas question d'en exclure
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 pour notre part
il me semble tout à fait possible et
respectueux de l'institution de réunir à
nouveau le parlement avant la fin de la
session ordinaire prévue le 27 février
prochain l'instauration d'une clause de
revoyure avant cette date nous
permettrait ainsi de faire un point
précis et contradictoires sur la
situation sanitaire et d'éventuellement
nous adapter en conséquence par des
dispositions nécessaires et
proportionnées comme l'avait souligné le
conseil constitutionnel dans sa décision
du 5 août dernier pour nous il n'est pas
envisageable de prolonger pendant huit
mois une loi d'exception qui comme des
mesures limitant ou interdisant la
circulation où les rassemblements nos
compatriotes pendant une période
électorale prolongeant le pass sanitaire
restreignant les déplacements à
destination en provenance du territoire
hexagonal de la corse ou de l'outre-mer
pour l'heure une clause de revoyure
n'étant pas envisagée par le
gouvernement au texte de loi qui nous
somme est aujourd'hui le groupe lr
votera donc pour la motion de renvoi
merci monsieur lorient n'a pas été
monsieur philippe vigier pour les
démocrates pour le modem et pour deux
minutes ainsi monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'écoutais philippe gosselin avec
beaucoup d'attention tout à l'heure et
lui dire que le goût démocrates ne
votera pas cette motion de rejet
préalable pour un premier argument
premier argument cher philippe gosselin
nous étions ensemble à la commission
mixte paritaire ou sénat et assemblée se
sont mis d'accord pour justement trouver
les outils qui permettaient d'adapter
cet état d'urgence sanitaire et vous
savez que j'ai porté avec vous avec
exigence le fait que l'on revient
jusqu'au 15 novembre et ça veut dire que
dans un débat tel qu'il a pu se produire
avec les parlementaires on a été en
capacité de se donner les moyens d'y
arriver et donc sur voter votre motion
de rejet préalable ça veut dire circulez
ya plus rien à voir il ya plus de débat
les amendements si on parle à moi
j'attends du débat qui va venir à ce
tome de garantie qui seront annoncées
j'imagine par le gouvernement sur les
clauses de revoyure sur le fait cher
philippe gosselin que la situation
sanitaire elle n'est pas maîtrisée par
tout ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure par
le ministre lui rendirent à un mot parce
qu'on a nos collègues dé guyane et
guadeloupe qui connaissent parfaitement
des situations partie est la preuve vous
étiez présent ça veut dire que l'état de
la responsabilité me semblait-il exige
que nous soyons à la hauteur et être à
la hauteur si justement à avoir un outil
mais il ya un mot qui nous a pas échappé
je le redirai tout à l'heure ces cas
c'est la 2 justement d'état d'urgence
sanitaire on va substituer un mot qui
pour moi un sens état de vigilance
sanitaire ce n'est pas la même chose et
l'évolution du passage d'un état
d'urgence un état de vigilance ça veut
dire c'est une prise en compte d'une
évolution de la situation dont on doit
dire quelle est le fruit du travail que
nous avons fait tous ensemble depuis de
longs mois pour ces raisons là nous ne
voterons pas votre motion de rejet
préalable
merci monsieur bédié la parole est à
madame lamia el harrach pour le groupe
socialiste et pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président pour ma part
j'ai écouté attentivement le collègue
gaussin et j'ai cru déceler beaucoup de
colère dans son propos la dernière fois
c'est mon groupe qui avait présenté une
motion de rejet préalable et la question
en réalité les doubles on a d'un côté
les questions de fond et nous allons en
débattre très probablement sur est ce
qu'on continue ou pas la capacité donnée
au gouvernement à pouvoir instaurer le
pass sanitaires mais au delà même la
question du bien fondé du passani terre
sur lequel on aura l'occasion de revenir
au delà même du bien fondé de la
question de l'obligation vaccinale sur
laquelle vous refusez de vous prononcer
mais qui est en réalité totalement
implicite est sous-entendu dans ce pas
ça ni terre que vous avez instauré le
vrai sujet je crois mes chers collègues
qui doit nous interpeller collectivement
parce que c'est notre responsabilité
c'est celle de la forme comment est-ce
qu'on choisit aujourd'hui de consulter
le parlement alors vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre c'est la 11e fois
que nous réunissions pour débattre de
cela mais j'ai envie de vous dire
votre propre propos exacts il me semble
en juillet dernier à mesure à caractère
à situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
donc je ne vois pas en quoi il serait
dommage que vous veniez devant le
parlement pour que celui ci puisse
exercer le devoir de contrôle qui est le
sien et heureusement que vous le faites
simplement ce que vous nous dites là
aujourd'hui dans ce texte c'est que vous
souhaitez que vous nous donnions que
nous vous donnions pardon un blanc seing
pour être en capacité de faire
exactement ce que vous souhaitez dans
les dix mois qui arrivent par dont les
huit mois et demi qui arrive et ça c'est
pas acceptable
c'est une mesure qui vient restreindre
nos libertés de façon importante quand
bien même et encore de battre tout à
l'heure il peut y avoir effectivement un
regard de la vaccination lie à cette
disposition on peut là aussi en discuter
mais simplement je ne crois pas que ce
soit une situation aujourd'hui est
acceptable et pour ce faire monsieur
gosselin mon groupe votre un la motion
de rejet qui est la vôtre
et je tiens à dire par ailleurs monsieur
le ministre qui serait très appréciable
que vous cessiez de considérer
systématique madame l âge la parole et à
monsieur dimitri houbron
à lire en forme pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président alors je
dois dire que j'ai été un petit peu
surpris au travers de cette motion de
rejet préalable que la critique
principale soit finalement l'absence de
débat démocratique
parler d'une motion de rejet préalable
c'est refuser le débat démocratique que
nous attendons tous ce soir et demain
dans cet hémicycle et puis
nous accuser le gouvernement et la
majorité de refuser le débat
démocratique c'est un peu léger quand on
voit que depuis demi depuis mars 2020
par dont c'est le dixième texte que nous
étudions avec toujours cet argumentaire
identique y est ce reflux donné des
prérogatives supérieur aux gouvernements
pour endiguer l'épidémie et puis il y a
ceux qui font des motion de rejet
préalable
et il ya ceux qui essaye d'être
constructif exams en demandant le groupe
agir ensemble le modem et l'as raismes
qui vise à encadrer justement les
mesures et notamment du passé ni terre
pour s'assurer qu'en effet il soit basée
sur des bases objectives et
scientifiquement prouvé
et puis quel bonheur mes chers collègues
et je pense que vous êtes comme moi
circonscription a retrouvé une forme de
liberté avec des événements qui se font
avec des sourires que l'on peut voir sur
les visages grâce aux mesures prises
notamment par ce gouvernement et je dois
le dire les retours des citoyens
sur les sur le terrain il est positif
parce que ce gouvernement a pris les
décisions difficiles
c'est ce parlement a pris des décisions
difficiles en donnant les moyens aux
gouvernements d'agir et puis je
conclurai peut-être sur le thème des
libertés avec les mots de françoise
bourdon qui disait que trop de personnes
croient que la liberté est gratuite
alors qu'elle a un prix au contraire
bien plus élevé celui du devoir et de la
responsabilité
la parole est à metz que michael de mme
keller pour le groupe udi monsieur
monsieur le président je vais rappeler
ce qu'on a rappelés en commission
vendredi dernier puisque nous sommes sur
la même ligne que philippe gosselin pour
quelle raison le parlement ne peut pas
se réunir après fin février pour quelles
raisons expliquez-nous et de quoi avez
vous peur en fonction avec le parlement
puisque vous ne voulez pas le réunir ce
texte pour nous n'est pas un texte
sanitaire c'est un texte d'organisation
de la république et du respect du
parlement et nous ne comprenons pas
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il a fallu que
le parlement se réunissent à chaque fois
qu'il a fallu qu'on prenne des mesures
d'urgence le parlement s'est réuni il a
été là on pourrait le faire
effectivement après le mois de février
et je vais vous redire ce que je vous ai
dit aussi qu'en commission mettre dans
les mains du futur président élu doc on
ne sait pas qui c'est des mesures
d'urgence et mesure d'une telle gravité
je pense que ce n'est pas responsable
donc simplement pour cette raison on
nous devrions nous engager à nous revoir
et à faire évoluer les choses
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit tout
à l'heure je ne connais pas d'autres
gouvernements qui sont présentés aussi
aussi fréquemment devant un parlement et
bien dites nous aussi combien de quel
pays a maintenus aussi longtemps l'état
d'urgence tout est là en fait donc pour
toutes ces raisons monsieur le président
nous voterons la motion de rejet nos
collègues
merci la parole est un monsieur jean
hugues ratenon pour l'apprendre a tout
misé
[Applaudissements]
merci président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la commission qui
examinait dernièrement ce texte a montré
les limites du respect de cohérence du
gouvenement vous vous obstinez à
prolonger un régime d'exception jusqu'en
juillet 2022 vous vous nous dites que ce
projet de loi ne prévoit pas l'état
d'urgence éternelle non il retape
simplement sa disparition personne n'est
dupe dans cette assemblée même si bon
nombre font mine de comprendre le
contraire non que je baptiserait député
député robotisée au service du set d'un
système aussi je tiens à dire ici à
nouveau que nous sommes pour nous sommes
pour la vaccination mais contre
l'obligation vaccinale mais comme encore
une fois le pass annie terre est une
menace pour les libertés publiques
le pass dans une illusion de protection
sur le plan sanitaire mais en réalité
n'est rien d'autre qu'un pass
autoritaire il instaure une société de
contrôle permanent et je suis persuadé
que sur ce plan vous êtes d'accord avec
moi monsieur verrons autre aspect
pouvoir et pour exemple vous même
monsieur le ministre lors de la séance
des questions au gouvernement du mardi 7
septembre à la question comment le
gouvernement prévoit tic concrètement
d'adapter le déploiement du pass alité
dans les outre-mer vous avez répondu je
cite nous avons décidé de ne pas
appliquer le pass and it et dans les
territoires et pour des raisons que
chacun peut comprendre d'ailleurs suite
à votre déclaration
le préfet de la réunion vous contredisez
publiquement comment la population
peut-elle vous pourrez désormais quand
le président et vous même monté je vous
ai interpellé à ce propos lors de
l'examen en commission et sans me
répondent pris en flagrant délit de
mensonge vous êtes parti en courant ce
qui ne vous grandit pas en bref monsieur
le ministre texte n'a plus lieu d'être
et encore une fois nous le répétons il
est liberticide et créé une société
anxiogène
c'est en cours ces raisons que nous
voterons la motion présentée par nos
collègues et leurs
merci monsieur rap non la palette avec
que paul molac pour liberté territoire
et deux minutes
merci monsieur le président donc nous
nous sommes réunis 11 fois pour quel
résultat à quasiment aucun au mois de
mai nous refusons de voter
le pass sanitaires pour les actes de la
vie courante pression du gouvernement on
l'acceptent au mois de juillet
avons-nous discuté une fois ici de la
façon de lutter contre la maladie non on
nous a dit la vaccination c'est la seule
façon de le faire est donc acte
d'autorité ensuite on aurait pu discuter
aussi de la façon de lutter contre la
pandémie
confinement partiel total
territorialisée etc etc là non plus on
n'a pas pu en discuter puisque on donne
les pleins pouvoirs au gouvernement qui
ensuite fait ce qu'il veut bon bah
écoutez je pense que tout ça n'est pas
très bon pour la démocratie est
d'ailleurs nos concitoyens eux s'en
rendre compte parce que qu'est ce qu'ils
nous disent et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
vont pas voter bas ils nous disent à bas
les élus vous êtes bien gentil un mot
fuck d'ici qui dirige basse et la
technocratie et l'administration et vous
finalement vous servez pour le décorum
mais c'est bien ce qui nous lisent
et serait tenté de croire qu'ils ont pas
totalement tort donc l'incapacité du
gouvernement de pouvoir dialoguer avec
les oppositions qui est un phénomène
très français
mais tout de même donc il faudrait vous
donner les pleins pouvoir jusqu'en
juillet 2022 je suis désolé mais c'est
au dessus de mes forces le peuple m'a
donné une parcelle de pouvoir pour
l'exercer pas pour la redonner au
pouvoir exécutif nous sommes dans la
confusion des pouvoirs
merci m monaco la parole est à madame
karine le bon pour le groupe commune
pour le groupe gdr et pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre cher collègue monsieur
delfraissy président du conseil
scientifique évoqué hier encore dans la
presse un allègement probable du pass
sanitaires l'amélioration de la
situation justifiant pleinement cela et
nous voici aujourd'hui face à un projet
de loi proposant la possible prorogation
n'est pas sanitaires et voulant donner
le champ libre au gouvernement afin de
convoquer l'état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 alors réaffirmé
la nécessité urgente du pass tout en
parlant de lâcher du lest faudrait
savoir mais c'est pas seulement votre
manque de congruence qui posent le plus
de soucis aujourd'hui tout d'abord c'est
un réel déni de démocratie que vous
souhaiter imposer le prétexte que vous
utilisez celui l'urgence en effet en
rappelant que les députés terminent leur
session ordinaire le 27 février du fait
des élections vous affirmer que ces huit
mois sans contrôle sont nécessaires mais
quand bien même urgence ignorait faut-il
vous rappeler que l'article 28 de la
constitution a tout prévu et que rien
n'empêche la tenue de session
parlementaire extraordinaire
accepter le débat et rendre des comptes
au peuple à travers son seul et unique
représentant constitutionnel le
parlement c'est le fondement historique
même de nos république vous devriez
savoir que même suite à l'article 16
distribuant les pouvoirs exceptionnels
au président le parlement et convoquer
pour effectuer sa mission rien dans une
démocratie ne peut justifier de ne pas
convoquer des représentants du peuple en
cas de crise grave
je ne reviens pas sur votre proposition
d'une peine de prison pouvant aller
jusqu'à cinq ans pour l'utilisation
frauduleuse d'un pass ne faut pas
sanitaire soit autant que pour une
fraude fiscale ou pour une agression
sexuelle votre gouvernement pèche par
son manque de clarté confinant à
l'incohérence ou pire au mensonge éhonté
en effet selon les déclarations
gouvernementales début septembre le tass
ne s'appliquait pas dans les territoires
en état d'urgence sanitaire pourtant la
réalité était tout autre l'état
d'urgence a été levé la semaine dernière
à la réunion mais le pass ainsi que
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
s'ils appliquaient déjà en même temps
que dans l'hexagone et en martinique
guadeloupe guyane toujours en état
d'urgence le pass s'appliquent ne
cautionne ni rupture démocratique
démocratie
galite miens merci
mes chers collègues nous allons procéder
au vote je vous rappelle qu'il a été
demandé par le groupe l'est républicain
ce tout un public
bon attendez attendez c'est l'hémicycle
1 je n'ai pas encore dit mais vous le
savez cette science est retransmise en
direct voilà ya un et deux concitoyens
sont très attentifs à notre comportement
séance donc
alors c'est bon
monsieur blain
haye le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin
est clos
résultat
votants 254 exprimé de
154% 1 contre 153 la motion de rejet
préalable est rejeté
nous ouvrons la discussion générale
je suis demandé aux députés qu'il
souhaite regagner d'autres
réunions
de le faire rapidement et en silence
avant de donner la parole
à au premier orateur
non monsieur sa base tous
voilà premier orateur monsieur guillaume
groupe keshia pour la république en
marche et pour cinq minutes
dont rien
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant nous avons
retrouvé une vie normale ou quasi
normale les restaurants et les lieux de
vie de nos quartiers ont réouvert les
musées les cinémas les bibliothèques
aussi on y redécouvre la joie des
découvertes et des échanges nous avons
pu retrouver le chemin de nos activités
sportives depuis plusieurs mois nous
retrouvons la vie une vie quasi normale
en apparence quasi normal car nous le
savons et la très grande majorité des
français le savent la crise sanitaire
n'est à ce jour pas derrière nous elle
est encore une réalité qu'il nous faut
affronter et pour laquelle des mesures
de vie collective doit être prise pour
continuer d'endiguer la propagation du
virus mes chers collègues si nous en
sommes là c'est parce que les françaises
et les français sont totalement
mobilisées pour surmonter cette crise
parce que depuis le tout début il
applique les gestes barrière avec
attention parce que depuis que nous
avons le vaccin il répond très largement
présents pour se faire vacciner parce
qu'ils appliquent avec responsabilité
altruisme les dispositifs que permettent
qui permettent de freiner la propagation
du virus comme le pass sanitaires par
exemple si nous en sommes là c'est parce
que l'ensemble de nos personnels
soignants sont totalement engagés dans
cette crise depuis le tout premier jour
aussi si nous en sommes là c'est aussi
parce que nous avons su prendre avec
courage et responsabilité les bonnes
décisions et je tiens tout
particulièrement à saluer votre
engagement sans faille monsieur le
ministre et sachez pouvoir compter sur
le soutien du groupe la république en
marche mes chers collègues aujourd'hui
au moment où nous débutons notre nos
travaux sur son 11e textes législatifs
relatifs à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire l'épidémie est sous contrôle
sur la quasi totalité du territoire
national elle demeure inquiétante dans
certains territoires ultramarins tout
particulièrement en guyane où l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sera prorogé
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 la vie reprend
son cours depuis plusieurs mois et la
situation économique a retrouvé son
dynamisme d'avant mars 2020 dans ce
moment que nous vivons l'envi peut être
forte de lever les dernières contraintes
qui subsiste de se dire que tout cela
est derrière nous ce n'est
malheureusement pas le cas des
inquiétudes persistent l'entrée dans
l'hiver les fêtes de fin d'année la
possibilité de connaître d'autres
variantes la difficulté la difficile le
déficit le début de la campagne de
rappel qui nous oblige à demeurer
vigilants et à garder des outils nous
permettant d'endiguer la propagation du
cog vide c'est ce que le gouvernement
nous propose avec responsabilité
à travers ce texte en prorogeant
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2021 l'existence du
régime juridique de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et du régime de la gestion de
la sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
régime pour lequel nous sommes
actuellement ainsi que de ses outils
tels que le pass sanitaires bien entendu
nous entendons déjà les cris d'épouvanté
face à cette proposition et le débat
aura lieu pour notre part le groupe
l'appui comminges votera le dispositif
qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement car il est proportionné et
le mieux à même de nous permettre de
gérer la crise qui est devant nous
nous ne donnerons pas pour autant un
chèque en blanc au gouvernement nous
viendrons notamment renforcer les
dispositifs de contrôle parlementaire et
nous clarifierons dans la loi les
critères sur lesquels le gouvernement
s'appuie pour prendre les décisions
concernant la mise en place ou la levée
du pass sanitaires par ailleurs je tiens
ici à corriger une polémique que
certains dans une période de primaires
partisanes temps de faire monter une
polémique qui veut que par ce texte nous
donnerions d'outils malléable selon
notre bon vouloir durant la prochaine
campagne présidentielle il n'en est rien
aucun des outils qui nous permettent de
gérer cette crise sanitaire ne
représentera une entrave au bon exercice
de notre démocratie je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que conformément à notre
constitution le pass sanitaire ne peut
pas s'appliquer pour les activités
politiques syndicales ou cultuelles je
tiens ici à le préciser afin qu'aucune
confusion ne soit faite et entretenu oui
mais pour le moment le couvre feu
monsieur gosselin n'est pas autorisée
car nous ne sommes pas dans la période
d'état d'urgence sanitaire mes chers
collègues cette crise sanitaire nous
n'en sommes pas encore sortis le moment
n'est pas à l'abandon des outils
sanitaire qui nous permettent d'agir et
d'endiguer le virus suivre une telle
voie serait prendre le risque de faire
face à une nouvelle vague ce n'est pas
ce que les français attendent de nous
notre responsabilité est aujourd'hui de
rester vigilants notamment dans les
territoires où la circulation du virus
est forte ou repart à la hausse dans les
territoires où le taux de vaccination
est trop faible ou ceux où les services
de réanimation sont au bord de la
ceinture mes chers collègues je vous le
dis ne nous trompons pas nos concitoyens
n'attendent pas de nous des divisions
politiciennes entretenus sur le dos de
la crise non nos concitoyens attendent
de nous que nous agissions avec courage
et responsabilité que nous leur donnions
de la visibilité sur la manière dont
cette crise est gérée que nous leur
garantissons que nous sommes en mesure
de continuer à maîtriser cette crise
sanitaire à protéger leur santé à
maintenir les lieux de vie du quotidien
ouvert c'est cela que les françaises et
les français attendent de notre part je
vous remercie merci la parole est un
monsieur aurélien pradié pour les
républicains et pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
députés
l'accoutumance voilà le danger qui nous
guette
l'accoutumance aux lois d'exception
l'accoutumance aux restrictions de la
vie sociale l'accoutumance aux règles
sanitaires
l'accoutumance aux mesures qui échappe
au contrôle fondamentale des
représentants du peuple l'accoutumance
aux pouvoirs administratifs
devenu peu à peu plus puissants que les
décisions politiques
l'accoutumance aux directives aux règles
aux indicateurs en tous genres aux
statistiques et aux courbes
épidémiologique plus notre pays ça coûte
umra à cet état d'urgence permanent plus
nous perdrons une autre habitude
l'habitude de la démocratie pleine et
entière
mais m à peine 10 cela que j'entends
déjà le camp de la raison nous faire la
leçon et s'offusquer de notre alerte
démocratique à l'époque que nous vivons
exaspérante et oppressante il faudrait
choisir son camp l'idée même que nous
pouvons nous puissions nous alarme et
d'un affaiblissement continu de nos
règles démocratiques est devenu presque
impossible
aussitôt vous êtes considéré comme
irresponsable et pourtant il est temps
de nous interroger sur l'état de notre
démocratie et sur ce qu'il en restera
vraiment à la sortie de la crise qui est
irresponsable
ce qui pose des questions et rappelle
que la démocratie est fait de règles qui
ne peuvent être continuellement négligé
voire bafoué non désormais les
irresponsables sont ceux qui ne se pose
aucune question les irresponsables sont
ceux qu'ils s'habituent à des blanc
seing donné au pouvoir exécutif sans
contrôle réel les irresponsables sont
ceux qui acceptent aujourd'hui ce qu'il
refusait hier les irresponsables sont
ceux qui négligent la vie de notre
démocratie face à la vie sanitaire être
responsable au 10e texte sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire que nous examinons
ce soir c'est refuser de négliger nos
principes démocratiques les plus
élémentaires être responsable un an et
sept mois après le premier texte sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est refuser
de prolonger sans raison valable
plusieurs mois encore des mesures
d'exception qui en aucun cas ne peuvent
et ne doivent devenir la règle
circulez il n'ya rien à voir rihanna
débattre rien n'a limité dans le temps
rihanna encadré rihanna contrôler
s'habituer à gouverner sous l' empire d
état d'urgence de la menace de la
contrainte de la facilité et de la peur
est désormais devenu une faute une fois
démocratique je les dis mais aussi une
faute politique
l'état d'urgence permanent c'est la
défiance permanente la défiance est ce
qui empoisonne un pays c'est ce qui le
fracture le divise et l'empêchent de se
redresser depuis le premier jour de
cette crise sanitaire vous avez nourri
et alimenté la défiance la seule voie
pour retrouver la confiance qui manque
tant à notre pays et de retrouver un
fonctionnement normal et exigent de
notre démocratie toute notre démocratie
proposé de prolonger jusqu'au 31 juillet
2022 l'état d'urgence sanitaire les
mesures du pas salutaire du port du
masque de plein pouvoir pour de nouveau
confinement n'est pas conforme aux
exigences démocratiques depuis le 18
octobre
79 départements n'impose plus le port du
masque obligatoire à l'école
75% de la population est vaccinée 90 %
des plus de 60 ans le sont nos services
d'urgence ne sont plus saturé l'état
sanitaire est sous contrôle
rien ne justifie donc d'appliquer au
moins à venir jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle
un régime sanitaire de crise grave
j'assume de dire ici à cette tribune que
la société du pass sanitaire n'est pas
la société que nous souhaitons j'assume
de dire à cette tribune que la
démocratie d état d'urgence et de la
marginalisation du parlement n'est pas
la démocratie que nous devons souhaiter
pour notre pays j'assume de dire
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement que vous prenez de
mauvaises habitudes qui a bible et
abîmeront durablement l'exigence
démocratique
j'assume de dire mesdames et messieurs
les dociles députés de la majorité que
vous n'assumez pas pleinement votre
mission en refusant de fixer des limites
et un contrôle stricte au désir excessif
de ce gouvernement j'assume de dire à
cette tribune aux français qui nous
écoutent que désormais nous devons nous
inquiéter autant de la santé de notre
démocratie que de celle de nos
concitoyens depuis plus d'un an nous
avons soutenu les mesures sanitaires
lorsqu'elle se justifier mais
aujourd'hui elle ne se justifie pas nous
refusons de vous signer un blanc seing
nous refusons de sacrifier le contrôle
du parlement parce que nous sommes
député garant des libertés et d'une
démocratie exigeante nous nous
opposerons à vos excès autant pour la
santé des français que pour la santé de
notre démocratie
merci monsieur débuté il a par l'état
mais que philippe vigier pour le modem
et pour cinq minutes
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
sera porteur
j'écoutais à l'instant relié à pallier
paris d'accoutumance
moi je ne suis pas dans la coutume en de
l'affaiblissement du parlement je crois
qu'il ya quelques années que je veux
démontrer ici
simplement il est des situations un peu
exceptionnels auxquels notre pays est
confronté depuis 20 mois
et cette situation exceptionnelle a
exigé des mesures exceptionnelles et
d'ailleurs on a tous étaient là en mars
2020 pour donner des moyens pour qu'on
lutte contre cette pandémie il faut
jamais oublier le chemin qui a été
parcouru on entend moins inventive axe
on entend moins les anti-pacs sanitaire
c'était la privation de la liberté
j'avais osé dire que le pass sanitaires
au contraire c'était le pass de la
liberté quelques semaines plus tard où
en sommes-nous et j'étais présent dit
mme gosselin s'en souvient ce fameux
dimanche de l'impossible mais ce
dimanche de l'impossible chacun en
responsabilité a fait un pas vers
l'autre pour faire en sorte que le
gouvernement ait les moyens de
travailler
pour qu'au fond on puisse protéger nos
concitoyens et moi je n'oublie pas les
5000 morts je n'oublie pas le personnel
soignant qu'on envoyait au feu je
n'oublie pas cette communauté absolument
extraordinaire que l'on n'a pas ménagé
pendant de longs mois et qui est
toujours là vous savez dans notre groupe
des démocrates on a deux députés en
guadeloupe justine bénin max matter
saision et qu'une liste sans relâche est
ce que vous connaissez la situation
difficile qui est là-bas et d'ailleurs
chers collègues vous êtes allés sur
place ça veut dire que cette pandémie
dont j'espère comme vous
étant un peu aussi au coeur du système
cette pandémie et que j'espère que vous
vous qu'elles puissent être totalement
définitivement derrière nous on
s'aperçoit qu'il faut être extrêmement
prudent j'ai toujours lu avec la plus
grande des attentions les rapports du
conseil scientifique et lorsque les 6
octobre dernier nous dit le risque de
rebond épidémique ne peut être exclue
dans les mois qui viennent eh bien je me
dis prudence et d'ailleurs dans
l'aveyron au département vous connaissez
bien chers collègues aurélien pradié qui
proche de chez vous il ya eu je crois un
taux d'incidence important non mais ça
veut dire une chose il y en a qui nous
disent tout et gagner c'est terminé on
enlève tout et tout va bien y en a un en
angleterre boris johnson il s'appelle et
sa peur qu'on s'aperçoit quand même que
quelque part il ya eu un échappement
malheureusement pour cette maladie et
l'histoire des pandémies nous montre et
nous appellent à l'état de
responsabilité alors on passe il faut
sortir l'état d'urgence la présidente
tout à l'heure le disais tout à l'heure
qu'il faut se donner les moyens d'agir
donner les moyens d'agir au gouvernement
et ne pas transiger sur le contrôle
parlementaire saturé et et le chemin que
j'ai souhaité la preuve j'ai fait partie
de ceux qui avaient demandé à ce que
nous puissions sortir des urgences
sanitaires le 15 novembre avec le groupe
des démocrates on aura sur rendez vous
monsieur le ministre le 15 février ces
rappeurs mais je vous demande aussi
qu'on ait un débat au mois de février
parce que si un moment ou un autre voeu
de façon apaisée parler des choses il
faut pouvoir devant la représentation
nationale dire le chemin parcouru voir
d'où nous venons où nous en sommes et ça
ça me paraît indispensable parce que ça
permet à chacun de ne pas céder à la
moindre instrumentalisation politique
parce que si jamais il y avait plus
aucun texte on pourrait nous dire quand
on convoque le 15 mars tout va bien
c'est à des fins de décisions politiques
parce qu'on sait qu'il y aura des
échéances importantes l'année prochaine
mais nous pouvons siéger ce que 17 juin
d'ailleurs philippe gosselin vous en
souvenez j'étais de ceux qui ont dit au
sénat qu'as-tu moment nous étions prêts
à venir donc tout ça pour dire mes chers
collègues que il est indispensable que
c'est parce sanitaire doit évoluer vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre un
passage était inconditionnel des
indicateurs sanitaires tels que le taux
de vaccination de positivité du test de
dépistage d'incidence de saturation de
livres de réanimation cela me paraît
être des indices qui sont indispensables
si on veut demain avoir un passé n'était
encore plus efficace sur ce chemin nous
vous suivons un mot moi qui habite dans
un département frontalier d'un autre on
me dit de pas sanitaires si jamais on
l'a pas dans le département d'à côté
mais comment on fait mieux que c'était
un peu compliqué donc je suivrai pas ça
y est en national en revanche avec une
territorialisation de l'action et
d'ailleurs je l'avais répété et dire x x
territorialisation de l'action pour
qu'il puisse y avoir des mesures
contraignantes prises par les préfets
prises avec les élus locaux de manière à
ce qu'on puisse adapter la réponse à la
situation locale donc pour toutes ces
raisons nous accompagnerons le
gouvernement sur ce texte avec une
exigence une ligne rouge c'est que
naturellement le parlement puisse avoir
les instruments de contrôle et rapport à
la clé maintenant la prison je parle
sous votre contrôle j'exécute là dessus
vous ne transigez pas le teil du
conseiller et passe au conseil d'état on
aura toujours naturellement les
éclairages du conseil d'état mais sachez
que ce schéma-là la responsabilit était
pour nous se défaire en sorte que cette
pandémie on puisse enfin lui tourner le
dos et moi je pense qu'il faut une
dernière chose on a appris de nos
erreurs on a aussi appris de nos succès
regardons la france où lé programme dont
les pays qui nous entourent je crois que
nous avons pu rougir
merci la parole et à madame lamia et la
rage pour le groupe socialiste et pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous nous apprêtons à
examiner une nouvelle fois au onzième
fois un texte pour faire face à la crise
de sanitaires un texte qui permettra une
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire ou de la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire on a compris et des
outils de gestion de cet état d'urgence
un texte qui imposera au delà de la fin
du quinquennat et au delà de la fin de
la législature à nouveau les
dispositions relatives à la sortie ou à
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ce texte
c'est l'inscription jusqu'à l'été 2022
de 3 régime juridique d'exception dans
notre droit pourquoi y at il une
nécessité de proroger c'était à
d'exception pour une temporalité si
longue nous avons fait preuve et ça a
été rappelé par mes collègues notre
capacité à voter un tel régime dans une
temporalité très courte et j'aimerais
rappeler que le parlement est à nouveau
consultés dans des conditions plutôt
déplorable alors même que ce texte dans
son intention a été annoncé depuis le
mois de juillet dernier
élections ou non nous sommes en capacité
de nous réunir si nous sommes convoqués
et nous répondrons comme nous l'avons
toujours fait à ce devoir ce n'est pas
monsieur le ministre de la polémique
politicienne ou de l'opposition de
principe au gouvernement mais plutôt une
volonté de voir garanti les principes
qui régissent notre état de droit et
dont nous sommes garants je le rappelle
à nouveau aujourd'hui c'est notre
responsabilité collective de protéger la
république est de veiller à ce que les
institutions conserve la place qui doit
être la leur
l'inter législature je leur dis là aussi
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
n'existe pas encore moins lorsque la
crise dure depuis plus d'un an et demi
et que les outils pour y répondre vont à
l'encontre de bon nombre de libertés le
coc vite 19 fait désormais partir partie
de nos commun alors si nous devons
apprendre à vivre durablement avec le
virus nous devons le faire dans un
régime de droit commun nous ne pouvons
continuer de prolonger durablement ce
régime d'exception qui atteint
profondément notre état de droit le pass
sanitaire a probablement permis un
regain de vesle la vaccination lors de
l'été il est peut-être l'une des clefs
de l'excellente couverture vaccinale du
pays mais cela aurait pu se faire
autrement on a eu l'occasion de le
défendre en juillet dernier et je crois
là aussi l'avoir dit en commission il me
semble que ça s'inscrit en faux du
procès que vous essayez de nous
implanter sur une opposition de principe
qui irait à l'encontre de votre position
car voyez-vous notre hémicycle à des
nuances d'opposition on a eu l'occasion
de l'entendre et il est légitime que
nous puissions les exprimer sans nous
voir intenté de façon systématique un
procès dogmatique sur le passé ni terre
il faut pas oublier ce manque de clarté
et l'obligation parle implicite dont il
fait preuve il faut pas non plus que
nous oublions les multiples crises
passion dont il a été le fruit il est un
point de crispation et il le sera encore
celui de mise à l'écart de nos
concitoyens qui pensent que le pass
solitaire n'est pas une solution
acceptable et qui par conséquent
n'agissent pas comme nous pourtant il
est malheureusement entrer dans nos
pratiques anodine l'accès à n'importe
quel lieu se fait désormais en
présentant ce pass contrôlant identité
et vaccination par une personne qui
n'est pas détentrice de l'autorité
publique on avait eu l'occasion de le
dénoncer en juillet dernier nous ne
sommes plus dans une situation qui exige
un pass sanitaires et entendre de la
part du rapporteur un chantage
infantilisant disant en substance les
élus faire ce qu'on veut ou sinon
nouveau confine c'est absolument y but
est ce que c'est pas ça la démocratie
monsieur le rapporteur et vous le savez
presque 50 millions de nos concitoyens
sont aujourd'hui vacciner la campagne de
vaccination des troisième dose à
semble-t-il commencé et il semblerait
d'ailleurs que certains arbitrages
manque toujours sur cette campagne
troisième dose y aura-t-il un passe
temps ni terre sur la troisième dose
elle sera obligatoire pour les soignants
ou pas
le taux d'incidence par ailleurs est
désormais inférieur au premier side
alerte dans presque tous les
départements j'appellerai d'autant plus
votre attention mes chers collègues sur
un paradoxe j'ai eu là aussi l'occasion
de l'évoquer en commission celui d'une
fin de crise annoncé celui où les
provisions budgétaires pour lutter
contre l'épidémie seront en effet divisé
par trois d'ici 2022 et j'ai entendu
votre réponse monsieur le ministre sur
le fait que les commandes de vaccins
justifie cette baisse budgétaires alors
acton nous davance l'échec de la
campagne de vaccination troisième dose
acton nous davance le ralentissement de
la réalisation des tests se sont là il
me semble de paris hasardeuse concernant
une provision nécessaire dans le cadre
de notre budget et sur laquelle les
expériences précédentes aurait dû il me
semble nous servir alors je vous
interroge pourquoi maintenir des mesures
de restriction de nos libertés publiques
quand nous annonçons budgétairement une
sortie de crise si proche et ce dès 2022
nous nous opposerons donc à ce projet de
loi en l'état et il s'agit pas de
s'opposer pour s'opposer je vous le
redis monsieur le ministre si la crise
sanitaire se poursuit devient plus
virulente le parlement doit approuver à
nouveau une telle provocation nous ne
pouvons tolérer le blanc-seing accordé
au gouvernement pour une si longue durée
et la représentation nationale ne peut
pas être laissée de côté nous avons fait
des propositions qui n'ont pas été
écoutés et nous ne pouvons tolérer une
incitation à la vaccination par la fin
de la gratuité des tests de dépistage du
coc vie de 19 car ce régime de
contrainte ou les tests devienne payant
pour les non vaccinés n'est pas
tolérable donc pour toutes ces raisons
nous nous opposerons à cette prorogation
de ce trip état d'exception nous
proposons que le parlement examine avant
la levée nos travaux de fin de
législature une nouvelle fois la
pertinence d'une telle prorogation je
vous remercie madame et la parole et à
monsieur dimitri aubron pour agir
ensemble et pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
madame la prison de la commission des
lois monsieur leur apportant mes chers
collègues le grand constitutionnaliste
toulousain maurice hauriou définissez
l'état d'urgence comme un régime
d'exception une sorte de légitime
défense de l'état qui l'autorisent à
user de pouvoirs exorbitants de droit
commun lorsque sa survie ou celle de son
peuple est gravement menacée la loi
d'état d'urgence dans l'échelle de
réponse aux crises et la plus puissante
nous avons eu à faire depuis mars 2020 à
une crise sanitaire inédite notre pays
ses institutions son administration et
sa population ont su faire face avec
dignité et pragmatisme l'étude annuelle
2021 du conseil d'état les états
d'urgence la démocratie sous contrainte
le souligner les administrations
publiques ont été mises à rude épreuve
elles se sont révélées remarquablement
résiliente et l'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui a pesé sur la totalité de nos
structures a permis de nombre à nombre
de services publics de montrer leur
efficacité
le parlement aussi a joué son rôle c'est
aujourd'hui le 10ème texte sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire que nous discutons
des nuits de débats se sont tenus dans
cet hémicycle cependant nous dit le
bilan de la commission des lois plus de
92 eur
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis
le mois de mars 2020 nous avons
l'avantagé sur ce virus grâce aux
vaccins et la vigilance de tous les
français
cependant et monsieur ministre le
rappelle régulièrement bien que nous
ayons pris le dessus dans ce bras de fer
la situation sanitaire peu brutalement
dégénérer en l'espace de quelques
semaines plusieurs pays peuvent
malheureusement en témoigner
parce que le virus n'a jamais cessé de
circuler de danger demeure le premier
c'est l'apparition d'un nouveau variant
qu'ils soient plus contagieux et ou plus
létale et ou pire résistant aux vaccins
le deuxième et nous devons être
singulièrement mobilisés en la matière
c'est la désagrégation de notre
couverture vaccinale faute d'une
administration d'une troisième doses
pour les personnes les plus fragiles
sur ce dernier point souvenons nous de
la situation israélienne cet été
l'avis du conseil scientifique relatif
au projet de loi que nous examinons le
précise d'ailleurs cette instance
envisage toujours avec une certaine
prudence l'évolution de la pandémie de
kobe 19 elle considère je la cite que
les autorités sanitaires doivent
concerner dans la durée une capacité
juridique à agir en cas de nouvelle
vague épidémique durant les prochains
mois
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
pardon le groupe agir ensemble s'est
montré constructif en formulant de
nombreuses propositions pour apprendre à
bille avec l'aco vide nous félicitons du
fait que l'oreille du gouvernement est
toujours été attentive à ces dernières
en commission des lois plusieurs
amendements des trois groupes de la
majorité ont été adoptés il vise à
renforcer le contrôle parlementaire dans
le cadre de ce régime de gestion de la
sortie de crise sanitaire car la
vigilance bien sûr incombe voix exécutif
quant à la situation sanitaire mais elle
impose aussi aux pouvoirs législatifs
sur le pouvoir exécutif
en séance publique nous porterons deux
amendements le premier proposé par ma
collègue agnès firmin le bodo
permettrait de renforcer la protection
des données de santé des français en
effet et laboratoires et pharmacie
recours à des prestataires matic qui
facilite la transmission au siaep des
tests effectués par les par leur passion
une mise en demeure récent de la cnil
nous a alertés sur le fait que certaines
solutions informatiques n'assure pas un
niveau de sécurité suffisant et peuvent
donner lieu à des violations de données
particulièrement sensible et afin de
sécuriser l'ensemble du dispositif y
compris son alimentation par les
professionnels de santé cet amendement
rendra obligatoire le respect par ces
prestataires informatiques de mesures de
sécurité suffisantes ainsi que le
recours par ces professionnels de santé
au seul prestataire répondant à ces
conditions
un deuxième amendement porté par les
trois groupes de la majorité permettra
l'encadrement de l'usaj du pass
sanitaire les mesures prises en
application du régime de gestion de la
crise sanitaire quant à la mise en place
du pass sanitaire devons être justifiée
au regard des indicateurs sanitaires que
sont le taux de vaccination le taux de
positivité des tests de dépistage le
taux d'incidence ou encore le taux de
saturation des lits de réanimation cela
paraît être une précision de bon sens
qui aura pour effet de renforcer la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans les
décisions prises par nos dirigeants en
définitive et sans surprise le groupe
agir ensemble en responsabilité votera
en faveur de ce projet de loi je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député la
part est en effet michel zumkeller pour
le groupe udi indépendant et pour 20
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre à madame la présidente de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues état
d'urgence sanitaire sortie d'état
d'urgence gestion de la crise est
désormais vigilance sanitaire le
gouvernement joue tant sur les mots qui
semblent s'est un peu perdu lui-même il
s'agit pourtant d'un sujet essentiel
pour nos concitoyens que notre groupe
u10 et indépendant n'a jamais pris à la
légère souvenez-vous nous avons su être
force de proposition en la matière et
comme vous pouvez le constater nous
sommes comme toujours mobilisés pour
discuter des mesures de gestion de la
crise sanitaire nous félicitons de
l'évolution encourageante des taux
d'incidence de la coved 19 cependant
notre responsabilité nous appelle à la
prudence nous savons que le combat
contre l'épidémie n'est pas encore gagné
et à ce titre nous partageons votre
volonté de prendre les mesures
nécessaires à la protection de nos
concitoyens
mais pas à n'importe quel prix le débat
que vous nous proposez aujourd'hui nous
sommes en réalité plus être sanitaire
mais devient au fil des tec une réelle
question politique et institutionnelle
en premier lieu ce projet de loi vise à
nous maintenir dans un régime décès
d'exception
rappelons le la déclaration de l'urgence
sanitaire autorise le premier ministre à
prendre par décret des mesures limitant
la liberté d'aller et venir la liberté
d'entreprendre la liberté de réunion
ainsi que des mesures de réquisition et
des mesures temporaires de contrôle des
prix il s'agit de mesure exorbitant du
droit commun qui ne puise en légitimité
que dans leur nature temporaire au cas
où cela vous aurait échappé vous nous
demandez de valider le maintien de ce
régime au delà de l'élection
présidentielle personne ne saurait
prédire le résultat de cette élection
alors pour quelle raison on était voix
nous faire prendre le risque de confier
de tels pouvoirs à des extrémistes
c'est inacceptable et totalement
irresponsable
en second lieu ce projet de loi pose la
question de la place que la
représentation nationale doit occuper
dans ce débat comme pour les textes
précédents nous constatons que le
gouvernement demande un blanc seing pour
plusieurs mois or le parlement ne
saurait être spectateur de l'action
gouvernementale
ne vous en déplaise notre fonction
première est bien celle de voter les
lois nous avons déjà eu ce débat a donné
de nombreuses fois depuis mars 2020 et
pourtant vous feignez de ne pas
comprendre notre rôle véritable ce qui
est d'autant plus problématique que
souvent au lieu d'écouter les
parlementaires votre gouvernement s'est
trompé tromper pour les masques tromper
pour la fermeture des commerces soit
disant essentielles non essentiels
tromper pour la gestion de la campagne
de vaccination trompé quand vous avez
dans un premier temps refusé la mise en
place du pass sanitaires nous l'avons
proposé en décembre 2020 à ce moment là
vous l'avez refusé
le parlement peut et doit remplir
pleinement son rôle si par coutume nous
suspendons nos travaux le temps de la
future campagne présidentielle
législatives rien ne nous empêche de
nous réunir pour évaluer l'avancement de
l'épidémie est adapté à nouveau les
mesures sanitaires vous acceptez
d'ailleurs que nous soyons dessinateur
de rapport dont nous pourrions débattre
donc nous serions bon pour discuter de
rapport mais pas bon pour voter des lois
la triste réalité que la majorité refuse
purement et simplement le dialogue et
c'est très dommageable sur un sujet tel
qu'une crise sanitaire chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris il est hors de
question pour nous groupe u10
indépendant de renoncer à la parole que
nous portons pour nos concitoyens telle
est la raison de notre position à ce
texte que nous ne voterons pas en l'état
merci monsieur auclair l'appareil est à
madame mathilde panneaux pour la france
face aux mises et pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci président ministe collègues
regardez autour de vous on se croirait
presque dans un hémicycle on dirait
presque que nous sommes parlementaires
réunis ici pour discuter d'un projet de
loi pour l'amender pourquoi pas même le
rejeter nous sommes donc en démographie
c'est bien noté laissez-nous simplement
le temps de nous y habituer bon je dis
presque car après tout le parlementaire
n'a pas beaucoup parlementer ces
derniers mois la plupart des décisions
sanitaires majeurs se sont prises au
sein d'un conseil de défense couverts
par le secret défense c'est à dire pas
d'organigramme pas de relevé de
décisions simplement ce pauvre monsieur
attal complaints mais pas trop non plus
lui qui essayaient péniblement de
traduire en langage terriens les ordres
et les contre offres venues de jupiter
vous me direz que vous jouez le jeu ce
projet de loi est le cinquième du genre
cette année mais comme tous les autres
il est truffé d'ordonnancé sur lequel
nous n'avons pas notre mot à dire ainsi
les parlementaires s'ennuie
l'une des votes s'ennuyer tellement
qu'elle a abandonné son mandat pour se
carapater chez accor hôtels puisque vous
trouverez désormais plus de démocratie
dans un conseil d'administration au sein
du temple républicain
d'autres ont l'esprit et le portefeuille
ailleurs aux seychelles par exemple mais
attention certains d'entre eux se
rebelle
notre groupe la france insoumise trouve
même des alliés chez vos ma chronique
pur jus passablement irrité d'être sans
cesse confondus avec des paillassons
enfin bref quelle faveur vous nous
faites quel amabilités imaginez
collègues qu'un jour en macro ni notre
rôle soit de prendre nous mêmes les
décisions qui engagent le quotidien de
la population
imaginez le seulement puisque ce ne sera
pas pour cette fois ce projet de loi
prolonge un régime d'exception
soi-disant provisoire mais devenu
éternel tant et si bien qu'un enfant né
en 2015 aura passé les trois quarts de
sa vie sous un régime de cette nature il
consiste à donner un blanc seing au
gouvernement pour prendre des décisions
sanitaire lesquels proviennent toujours
de la même origine sur quel pied le
président de la république s'est il
levait pied gauche couvre-feu pied droit
déconfinement pied gauche passe
sanitaire qui est droit tout dépende de
quand il s'est levé du pied gauche voilà
le modèle
dits de gouvernement que vous avez
institué l'absurde 10 généralisée grâce
à ce texte vous remettez une fois encore
le quotidien des français dans les mains
du président qui pourra activer
désactiver aurait activé seul selon son
humeur le pass sanitaire puisque dans la
farce de la gestion de crise sanitaire
monsieur le premier ministre n'occuper
qu'un rôle de figurant
monsieur le premier ministre nous leurs
patrons autant qu'il le faudra nous
sommes contre le pass sanitaires le
conseil scientifique lui même et
d'initiatives sur son efficacité il est
votre excuse commode pour faire mine
d'avoir fait quelque chose contre le coc
vide quand vous n'avez pas fait
l'essentiel avez-vous augmenter le
nombre de lits non vous en avez fermé
5700 en 2020 avez vous un gaucher plus
de soignants non plus vous en avez
suspendu plus de 15000 avez vous une
vraie pour la levée sur les brevets non
pourquoi ce serait dommage de retirer la
mine de la manne de big pharma comme on
dit chez vous quand il n'ya pas de
profil n'y a pas de plaisir sans oublier
le fameux vaccin qui ne sera pas
obligatoire ou encore se passe sanitaire
qui ne sera jamais au grand jamais un
droit d'accès qui différencie les
français d'après emmanuel macron vous
avez fixé des dates couperet au delà
desquels vous agiter la menace de
suspension de tests payant qui vous
évite de vous adresser à l'intelligence
des français voici où nous en sommes
comment la population peut-elle croire
et vous croire alors que le président
lui a si copieusement menti il n'y a pas
de politique sanitaire sans confiance en
guadeloupe à peine 40% de la population
a reçu une première dose de vaccin au
chu de pointe à pitre 45% des soignants
sont vaccinés vendredi en martinique des
soignants et leurs patients ont été
gazés dans un hôpital par des policiers
qu'allez-vous faire les matraques et
encore et encore
aurait encore allez vous renvoyer chez
eux ces soignants qui ont fait des
toilettes à l'autre cologne qui ont été
à court de masse de gants de médicaments
de respirateurs ou de lit
aux antilles la méfiance des citoyens
s'inscrit dans une histoire plus longue
celle du chlordécone et plus récemment
celle des déboires liés à la pénurie
d'eau qu'attendez vous monsieur le
ministre pour déclencher le plan orsec
eau potable qui prévoit de distribuer
des bouteilles d'eau à la population qui
n'en a pas au robinet car monsieur le
ministre vous ne pouvez pas demander à
une population d'à que les gestes
barrières quand il n'y a même pas d'eau
pour se laver les mains convaincre
plutôt que de contraindre sachets
collègues que ceci n'est pas une idée
nouvelle on pourrait en faire l'histoire
tant la philosophie morale la tient pour
acquise depuis des siècles rousseau
parler de la loi des plus forts en ces
termes qu'est ce qu'un droit qui périt
quand la force cesse s'il faut obéir par
force on n'a pas besoin d'obéir par
devoir et si on est plus fort c'est
d'obéir on y est plus obligé collègues
voici votre erreur fondamentale le
consentement à l'autorité ne se fait pas
sous la contrainte nous voterons contre
ce texte ce texte sont vos égarements
imposer aux français depuis deux ans ce
texte est une occasion pour vous d'en
commettre bien d'autres
prochaine séance ce soir un monsieur
ministre non prochaine séance ce soir
21h30 c'est du projet de loi portant
diverses collections vigilance sanitaire
la séance est levée